this is jocko podcast number 348 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
we are turning our society upside down
one khmer rouge officer told the
newsweek reporter in the weeks after the
revolution
the people of phnom penh
will grow rice
he said
and almost as an afterthought added
they will work
or starve
by early may 1975 the khmer rouge were
implementing one of the most radical
political plans of the 20th century a
peasant revolution with a punitive edge
buddhist monks were made to plow fields
pagodas were turned into killing centers
cham muslims a religious minority were
force-fed pork
cambodia's national library was
converted into a pigsty
in paul potts democratic kampuchea
books were used to start fires
it was more about revenge recalled one
cambodian
all private property even money was
abolished in this
ultra great leap forward
early accounts of life under the khmer
rouge came from cambodian refugees who
escaped to thailand at first they
sounded too bizarre to be true as if
george orwell had written them to
satirize life under a dictatorship of
the proletariat a place where parents
feared their children and civilians were
slaughtered in numbers and for reasons
unimagined since stalin's purges or
hitler's third reich
survivors described a system of slave
labor
communes where men women and children
toiled like human water buffalo under
the watchful eye of the mysterious and
all-powerful leadership cabal known only
as angar
they lived in perpetual fear
the cia held little hope for america's
former allies and educated cambodians
quote executions are reported widespread
and in many cases members of the entire
form family of former government
officials or soldiers are executed along
with the heads of the family
almost all executions occur in the same
manner several communist cadres beat the
person to death with hoe handles or
other blunt instruments end quote
not only did the khmer rouge eliminate
family life they made sex before
marriage a capital offense
khmer rouge survivor yuk chang
remembered watching two young lovers
beaten to death in front of his entire
commune
in a larger sense the khmer rouge were
threatened by all expressions of love
between husband and wife parents and
children friends and colleagues observes
elizabeth becker
one khmer rouge survivor is still
haunted by his mother's final words
you have to learn how to live without me
lang thirth khmer rouge minister of
culture and social affairs stated quote
only children can purely serve the
revolution and eliminate reactionism
since they are young obedient
loyal
and active end quote
so
that right there is a
little excerpt from a book called facing
death in cambodia it's written by a man
named peter maguire
and peter has also written
about the nuremberg trials about the
treatment of nazi war criminals
but his focus has not always been
on war or genocide
he actually has a pretty significant
dichotomy in his life peter maguire grew
up a surfer in southern california
that led to chasing the
mythical endless summer that many
surfers pursue
and he funded that
chase
[Music]
by
drug smuggling
eventually he left that life for
academia
where he received his doctorate in
history
along the way he became a jiu jitsu
practitioner
he's a historian
an author a defense contractor college
professor
and he's lived an extremely
multi-faceted life and it is a privilege
to have
peter maguire here with us tonight to
share some of his experiences
and some of his lessons learned
well thank you for having me yeah thanks
for coming out
uh i guess
how did you and i originally connect
surfers journal
i interviewed you but how did you did
you just reach out somehow through ivan
i think through ivan man yeah so ivan
trent is a
is his former seal
and the the reason i knew about ivan
trent well when i got to on my first
deployment
i was on my first deployment i went to
guam
and i walk in to like the the
headquarters area and there's a picture
hanging on the wall of a guy dropping in
on a giant wave big hawaiian wave and
it's signed you know it says you know
some quote
ivan trent and i'm like that's
interesting well it's buzzy trent's kid
and buzzy buzzy trent is one of the
iconic guys that opened up big wave
surfing for the world
and his son was a seal
and so
you did an article about
how did you know ivan
i knew ivan through
the combat rescue boat that i did with
george greeno and so ivan
uh our fathers surfed together in you
know malibu in the 50s
and so
um
yeah and so i reached out to ivan and he
was our greatest help and uh a true ally
and we became great friends and i stayed
with him in virginia beach whenever i
went there and would have to
do jiu jitsu with his son on the on the
carpet i think his son might train here
and uh and then his little chihuahua dog
would try to hunt my leg yeah so i
haven't had chihuahuas
that's uh speaking of dichotomy there
you go
well
let's get into it um
and just let's go through kind of how
you ended up here because you have been
on a wild ride
i mean a little bit
relatively speaking your life's been a
wild ride so you're born
in 1964.
uh tell us about your tell us about your
mom and dad
my mother was
one of the first women screenwriters in
uh
in hollywood joan tewksbury she wrote
robert altman's nashville among other
things
um she was actually
the ostrich in mary martin's peter pan
on broadway
she was
a child kind of shirley temple
in hollywood grew up in hollywood and my
father um
was the son of a famous pilot robert
mcguire who ran operations magic carpet
and operations alibaba flying yemenites
and concentration camp survivors to
israel so at 14 my father was a
mechanic's assistant in tel aviv airport
he was flying missions with my
grandfather he was flying at 14.
um i think it wasn't dc3s but it was one
of those big silver well how did that
how did that happen
my grandfather was a pilot in world war
ii and then alaskan airlines was hired
to
resettle jews in israel
so
that's originally how he got involved
but then alaskan airways pulled out and
he set up a company called far eastern
air transport
and uh
flew a remarkable number of hours uh in
a short amount of time
and
ben gurion called them
the irish moses and the last chapter of
leon euris's exodus is called the king
crab king and that was my grandfather
who lived at rincon right at the
indicator and so
so my dad was a real wild guy he died
about a year ago and he
so
you know he gets goes to tel aviv his
mother their parents are divorced she
finds out that he's being raised by
wolves in the middle east so they send
him to a fancy french boarding school
he so this is your dad my dad and so
then he
gets to the club so hold on so your
dad's mom realizes that your kid is that
your dad is like a feral child
exactly missions yeah and says we're
gonna get him the hell out of there yeah
we're gonna take him and send him to a
french boarding school yeah and so they
sent him there and the french couple
that was supposed to be taking care of
him took the money and ran
and so he and an older kind of french
nobleman whose parents had been killed
in the holocaust
said let's not tell anybody and so they
basically ran away and spent the better
part of a year riding bikes around
france going to nice going to the
hookers going to the whole shebang and
then he moved to california after that
and there was no hope for southern
california and so he became one of the
biggest real estate developers in los
angeles he built playa vista and much of
the skyline and uh they called him the
cat with 10 lives and so it was a boom
or bust life like you know up one day
and then hey kids we're moving and
you're going back to public school
so
in my dna
i knew
the only thing that couldn't be taken
away from me was an education
i knew there would be no
inheritance nothing and he went public
in i think 2008 2009
had a billion dollars cash
and uh
then bet it all on black
and
basically bought the blackstone group's
real estate portfolio two weeks before
the subprime crisis
and lost it all
and so uh he passed away about a year
ago and uh
inherited a few lawsuits
and so that's what you got yeah but he
was a classic guy you know and and uh
and so
you know i just big things were expected
of you as a kid i mean my grandpa had
that we always had boats and if
ventura my grandpa lived in the ventura
keys and if ventura harbor was closing
out well that was a good day to take out
the boat
like let's punch through yeah yeah and
like so that was not anything
out of the ordinary for me and so
when i first took my job
uh i got my phd at columbia
my phd advisor was brigadier general
telford taylor the chief prosecutor at
nuremberg and i had friends who had set
up a non-profit
to
collect the photographs taken at tool
slang prison the khmer rouge's central
torture and execution facility roughly
20 000 went in
roughly 20 survived everyone got their
picture taken
so they were preserving the negatives
and the photographic record
at that time the khmer rouge was still a
major force to be reckoned with so this
is what this was 93-94
so i go there in early 94
and it's very volatile the un has this
incredibly
absurd
occupation where they treat the uh you
know neutrality is the sacred principle
so it's the it's the un's model that
goes wrong in the 90s so the khmer rouge
are a lot you know allowed to run in the
election they're treated
you know there's no accountability
there's you know khmer rouge killed
roughly
you know we think 2 million out of 10
million it's like a quarter of the
population yeah in three years 10 months
20 days most of them you know with with
an ox cart a handled
axle to the back of the head
and
no accountability
when the khmer rouge falls in early 79
um thailand china singapore the us all
back them and so then
pol pot at al uh become freedom fighters
and so um so it's just too bizarre you
couldn't make it up and so there's
absolutely no accountability and i knew
from my nuremberg researches the only
thing
in that kind of situation an unresolved
conflict still fighting going on
is historical accountability it's
preserving the empirical evidence of the
crimes so that was very important to me
also was building the chains of command
from the bloodstained butcher who's
usually the scapegoat it's easy to to
try lindy england or these kind of
people and uh the garden variety you
know sort of uh perpetrator but to move
up to the chain the food chain like they
did at nuremberg to get the shot callers
policymakers that's what i was more
interested in the senior leaders and um
so that was my goal i also wanted to
link them to their uh
their masters the chinese government
because you know this was a chinese
sponsored affair
there were chinese advisors throughout
cambodia during the khmer rouge years
and the chinese have never copped to it
and they still we didn't support
the bad policies and you know and they i
was there when xing zhang main came for
the first time
and we went to the press conference and
and one of my friends from the wall
street journal said what about
accountability what do you say to
cambodians and and he just started
screaming at him and went no and stormed
off the podium and i went wow this is
this is a different kind of press uh
conference than i've ever been to um so
that was my initial
foray was you know with these
photographs finding the survivors but
then i was able to find the perpetrators
and i worked with uh
a pretty remarkable guy named soccin who
was uh he said um
uh i'm a remarkable survivor and i use
the weapon of the mouth
and and i said how did you survive the
khmer rouge she goes i worked harder
than any man and i sang revolutionary
songs louder than any man yeah and so
soxin was a rough guy and uh he
you know started as a pedicab driver and
one of the guards at the hotel that was
the fancy hotel the press stayed would
whip him with a chain because he'd be
too aggressive so the chain that blocked
the driveway he'd whip socks in with so
every time saxon got a new car he would
pull it up to that same guard who'd been
there for 20 years guarding that gate
honk the horn and wave at him and so um
saksin taught me a lot about cambodia
probably just driving around with him i
learned as much as you know and and he
would see two young lovers on a
motorcycle and and he was like i cannot
look and i'd say why he goes he goes i
miss that i i didn't get that in my life
like too painful too painful and uh
it was just amazing what those people
went through and
you know one of my students a professor
now
named so paul eare
his parents were sort of elite
cambodians they pushed their mercedes
out because the khmer rouge came in
april 17 1975. they said oh we're just
leaving for a little while the american
bombers are coming you know just so
they're pushing their mercedes right and
one of the kids gets separated never
sees them again and then the father dies
the men always die the women survive the
cambodian women kept that society
together
very similarly how the the southern
women did after the civil war and uh
but much more extreme anyway um
they go to one of those horrible rice
gulags where you know they're barely
given enough calories to survive
and they announce okay any vietnamese
we're going to allow out
but you have to take this vietnamese
language exam
you fail that exam you die and so she
had had vietnamese maids so they coached
her got her vietnamese back up to speed
she passed the exam so now they go to a
refugee camp in vietnam
she finds a phone book and i don't know
how starts dialing numbers in paris gets
a sponsor
the family gets to go to paris she works
as a seamstress
then she finds out she has a relative in
san jose or oakland
they come to the united states
she makes sure
that she gets a fake address in the best
school district
in san francisco makes her kids take the
bus two hours each way
every one of those kids today doctor phd
you know
those are the immigrants we want right
yeah no we just uh
we just we just did another podcast and
we were talking to
um
talking about some vietnam vietnamese um
immigrants that came over after the war
that had gotten out and it was the same
story for all of them they'd all worked
so hard
and all their kids ended up just you
know doctors uh you know engineers just
the whole nine yards and because
education was so highly valued for them
after they were able to get out of
vietnam and after you know basically
everyone that they knew that stayed back
was murdered oh yeah um awful just awful
how that how that unfolded
uh
let let's rewind a little bit we kind of
jumped straight into cambodia but you
took a strange path to get to cambodia
yeah
so you're born in 1964 yeah
that's kind of a cool time to be growing
up and you grew up where in malibu
malibu pacific palisades yeah santa
monica canyon so this is like 19 you're
what time did you start how old were you
and you started going down to malibu by
yourself and surfing all day which i'm
sure you must have done all the time
well we had a house
in carpinteria and then my grandpa lived
at rincon so we were going to santa
barbara pretty much like on the rincon
little point there the cinder block wall
at the indicator
and that's how i met george greeno
you know it was about 10 years old and
so i had a charmed life i could go surf
the bixby ranch and drive in
and um the channel islands
and i had a very charmed i was you know
i was a privileged kid and uh
and
you know malibu i lived in the colony as
a very little kid then we moved away but
i still knew all those guys so then i
lifeguarded in malibu colony which was
quite a quite an experience but we were
bad so this is now the so this is now
what the 70s when you when did you
graduate from high school uh 83
83 and i was
start like you said going to malibu with
the older guys
smoking weed in the back of the pickup
you know probably
13. what kind of music were you
listening to oh led zeppelin and uh
cream
and uh
yeah that you know
some eagles but yeah and um
but yeah we were bad and we were like
free-range children all our parents were
divorced
um
very permissive time
i mean there was especially in malibu
bizarre like
one of our friends mothers had a primal
scream room that you like walked through
a giant vagina to get into
and uh just bizarre
wait well it's a primal scream you'd
have to expand on this one bro you go
i'm not familiar yeah you go in this
room and you scream
and you let it all out and uh and then
there was you know there was there was
uh orgies and this kind of stuff so what
are your parents doing at this point
like my mom was making her way in
hollywood and my dad were they together
i lived with my mom till i was uh about
and then she knew i needed a dad and uh
put me with my dad my dad was a hard ass
like i was bad and uh and he kind of he
had a thing where he would wake you up
at five in the morning
and then he'd say come downstairs we
need to talk
and uh and he was always the throw
weight in all the union stuff in l.a
because he owned all the buildings so
what he did with labor was how the str
how the strikes went everything and he
usually sided with labor and so he would
uh sit you down
and he would just inventory the litany
of your sins that you didn't think you
thought you were getting away with
everything right and and it was so
startling and uh and then he would just
hand you okay this uh yeah this address
you need to be down there tomorrow
morning at five and it was the uh
afl-cio local 300. you're going to get
something yeah union hall
and uh so he made me work as a union
laborer
on the high-rises but little did he know
my my
you know this was the punishment job and
it was a graveyard shift eleven nights
at six in the morning but i worked with
all uh daryl strawberry's family so my
marijuana empire expanded exponentially
because back then
the there was green there was green pot
in the winter and brown pot in the
summer and you know and thai
and the inner city la couldn't get any
of it no one dared you know no white
boys dared go down there and so i did
and uh
i go
down i'd go to venice because i knew
some guys from the venice gangs through
athletics and then i would go down the
crenshaw area with those guys and i
write about that in my book thai stick
and then um
yeah and then i got i got busted when i
was 19. so hold on so okay
so it seems like your dad i mean you
your dad owns all these buildings
what what's what's getting you to you
you had to have looked at that even as a
15 16 17 year old and said hey man my
dad's doing all right
i can probably figure out some kind of a
livelihood by working with my dad
but how do you end up getting in the pop
business
um
i i don't know i just did it was easy it
was right in front of me the
you know the surfers controlled the
high-end marijuana trade and so
particularly the thai trade and so i
you know wrote in tystick that the
arrival of the thai marijuana fleet
marked the beginning of summer
so the older surfers that i looked up to
and i would see these guys fly into
scorpion bay i mean i first went
scorpion bad thinking 79
and it was guys on the lamb i mean it
was a shady place and it was hard to get
to and so you know 16 years old crossing
the mountains from the from the sea of
cortez you know in my old man's suburban
and um
and you know these guys would fly in for
low tide and cessna's and really good
surfers and then they'd you know they
they'd give us some cold beer because we
didn't have ice you know like ice was
the best commodity
and it's okay we got to go back to kabul
for happy hour and you know and they led
this charm life you know oh north shore
in the winter
indonesia you know in the summer baja in
the summer these so these guys were on
the endless these guys were literally on
the endless summer train and they were
fueled by marijuana financed by pot yeah
and so so
thai
pot so you said it was green i forget
what you said i'm not familiar with pop
because i i spent my whole life well i
was in the military for 20 years i grew
up as like a straight edge hardcore kid
so yeah i don't know
enough about pop well now educate me
yeah well well i call i call it
frankenweed now like it's gone way
beyond
we had the what we called purple
seedless which was the northern
california pot isn't that supposed to be
good like oh yeah california okay yeah
it was the best now but it's this weird
gmo pot that that's the frankenweed i
don't like that stuff and i don't think
it's i don't think you should be smoking
it all the time um so pot has has left
me uh you know way behind but anyway
so that would pretty much run out that's
so it was a real adam smith supply and
demand thing
so there was not unlimited amounts of
good green pot all year round so what's
the brown pot that would be uh
would be mexican colombian inferior pot
with seeds and this and that but then
the thais
were master growers and the famous thai
stick right and so you had pot
in the early 70s worth two thousand
dollars a pound
and so
one sailboat full
you're a millionaire you know and so
that's why so many surfers got involved
in it because what do surfers need they
need freedom and they need time
so one sail boat full
you're a millionaire and this is in the
70s so that million you're good for life
pretty much exactly
and then you know then you go i'll do
another well i'll do a bigger boat oh
you know and then all of a sudden you're
dealing with thai gangsters you know
bringing it across the border and pmex
gas trucks paying million dollar bribes
i mean
like you know remarkable tradecraft
actually and then that's where i learned
a lot of tradecraft
you have this quote so you wrote a book
called stick i'm gonna pull a quote from
it right now um
it says uh one afternoon a long-haired
well-traveled surfer came into the surf
shop and after exchanging warm greetings
and elaborate handshakes with the
shopkeeper he threw a big plastic bag
filled with greenish brown plant matter
onto the counter and said
thai sticks bro
that same summer my friend found his
older neighbor's stash of tie sticks and
stole one
so it was just like this seemed like the
thing you also had another good quote in
there the quest for utopia turned into
self-indulgence and narcissism the beach
was an escape a constant and stable
refuge during a time of uncertainty this
is like the 70s yeah absolutely and yeah
as i said almost all of my peers parents
were divorced
and
you know and
luckily athletics grounded me very much
right what athletics what were you doing
baseball basketball football from five
years old to 14 years old every season
with the same guys you know pop warner
and you know we were the palisades
dolphins light blue uniforms with
dolphins on our helmets about 40 blonde
haired white boys and our schedule was
watts
crenshaw
and that wasn't even the bad teams like
pico rivera with these like these
mexican teams running the wishbone you
know and you're just like what what is
this yeah and we're in our dorky little
you know palisades dolphins you know but
there were some great athletes who came
out of the palisades steve kerr
jay schrader
so it was interesting because back then
la was not segregated
so we were
you know we were going up against the
best of the blacks had to offer the best
the mexicans had to offer and we had a
lot of mutual respect for each other
through athletics so what is it
segregated now
i would say the la riots changed things
dramatically and i saw with my younger
half siblings
they didn't you know they stayed in
their little you know enclave yeah and
it
would wasn't good you know and uh
and then i you know then i went to
private school and and it was this is
once you turn 14 15 or whatever yeah so
i was public school until seventh grade
then i got sent to a very difficult um
prep school
despised it fought it every step of the
way did you have to wear a uniform and
stuff no but just had to do about four
hours of homework a night
and uh yeah and you know we fought a lot
in public school i mean back then we all
went to a park after school and played
sports unsupervised always and people
fought all the time and it was a very
honest hierarchy and um
and so i had a guy try to bully me at
the private school and i was like oh you
got to be kidding me and so i waited for
cross-country running day so we could
get the furthest possible away from the
coaches and then tripped him
at from behind and then just
just he and he and i let him bully me
like i i you know i you know from
fighting a lot of it's acting and so i
got him like
like salivating and uh
and then you know i i probably hit him
15 times in the face
unanswered he didn't even put his hands
up
and then
no but then he had then he had like
weird knots all over his head from that
day forward and i won't tell you his
last name but it begins with an l and
his name
he became lumpy l after that day and
then nobody bothered me at private
school anymore and then i wasn't invited
back because i'd been on academic
probation and was starting to turn
pretty bad by about 10th grade
and um and then i went to a very very
fancy
movie star kid very permissive
uh very liberal school in santa monica
and uh
and that's where i really went back
because
i had some i had an old buddy from
sports
whose family were all big crips and so
he was there as the basketball ringer so
they had this ringer basketball team and
so we were involved in all kinds of you
know selling weed
charging people to park at their own
high school um
it wasn't pretty and uh i wasn't nice
and what's your what's your dad doing
during this he's just working his ass
off working his ass off kind of has a
new family new wife
uh and you know i would they're just
like but they would say well how's peter
doing my dad say well there's still sand
in the house so he's alive
and and that was about it and so then
yeah
and i was the only one who didn't go to
college i moved to australia at 18 to
surf and uh
and
had an incredible time you say this in
in the book thai sticks our extreme
confidence in the ocean often translated
to dangerous sense of freedom and
arrogance on land at 14 i was busted by
customs at tijuana border trying to
smuggle fireworks at 16 i was sneaking
onto private government property to surf
waves guarded by barbed wire fences no
trespassing signs and men with guns at
19 i moved to australia never looked
back
there was very little we were not
willing to do if it enabled us to serve
perfect uncrowded waves
whether it was bringing a few cases of
canadian whiskey through this through
the surf during prohibition poaching
some illegal mexican lobsters for
mobsters in vegas working on the
gambling boats anchored in international
waters off santa monica pier or
offloading
or offloading a load of thai marijuana
california watermen had always been part
of the black market fast money
fast money bought time and freedom
that's like a history of what surfers
have been doing for the past since since
the prohibition of crying out loud
um
you say by 16
marijuana was my daily bread
without which no surfing session was
complete although there was a western
surfing association a national
scholastic surfing association a
christian surfing association and
probably even a republican surfing
organization my peers and i were members
of the marijuana surfing association not
all surfers smoked pots some were
adamantly opposed to it but for us pot
and surfing went hand in hand not only
was smoking an anesthesic for that
dulled life's sharp edge it was above
all an effective time killer for our
endless waiting whether it was a swell
to come the tide to drop or the wind to
change we always seem to be waiting for
something
you know when uh one of the things that
i tell people a lot and it seems like
you're just knee-deep in this
when you're young you don't connect
what you're doing right now with your
future and i think that's a huge problem
it leads kids to do the wrong things
because they don't recognize that oh
what i'm doing right now
this is going to impact my future
whether they're not thinking about their
future or they don't think they can get
caught or they think they can get away
with anything or they think they're
immortal all those things
it seems like you were just knee-deep
into hey i'm living for the moment right
now that's it yeah absolutely yeah and i
it took a long time to repair the damage
um because i went to australia
um
so so did you you graduated from high
school yeah and then once you graduated
from high school now you're 18 19 years
old no no i'm 18. so you're 18 years old
and
does your dad want you to go to college
did you get good grades no but i was
always working i always had a couple
jobs so i was always i had a union job
or you know i was i was
i was never lazy and i was always
motivated
just by
not traditional things and so
i would work my ass off and then i would
sell you know pot on top of that but
you know very kind of only pot only to
adults
only large quantities never to kids or
like a dealer i really kind of frowned
on that
and um
and
just saving all my money for the big
surf trip right and uh and so i did that
for about 10 months after high school
then i i flew to australia and i lived
at broken head point between byron bay
and lennox head with a
famous old
shaper named michael cundiff and george
greeno was our neighbor who i knew a
little bit from santa barbara and it was
just bliss and i traveled all over
australia with some of the best surfers
of the time
one of my best friends was a guy named
ant corrigan who
was the best surfer of his generation
schoolboy cadet
champ
they wanted him on the pro tour
he went to work at the pub instead and i
loved the aussies because they didn't
care if you're a dick you're a dick and
they're going to call you out on it and
you know the pubs and the drinking and
fighting and fighting and fighting and
uh
you know it was a wild time the aussies
and uh
and i had a ball and then i went to
uh i went to micronesia i served
micronesia new caledonia
fiji before tavarua
then french polynesia
and then i had um
i had a
tahitian girlfriend
and i thought i had died and gone to
heaven and i'm there and
it just it was too good and then
suddenly so now are you 19 now yeah i'm
19. you're 19 years old damn that's
you're rolling and so suddenly
a strange car pulls up in the driveway
and i look okay so you wait a second now
you're in tahiti at this point yeah you
got a tahitian girlfriend at her house
you're surfing
living the dream yeah
and
you're in her house yeah living there
staying there and now what do we get
strange car pulls up
fat middle-aged frenchman jumps out
eyes pop this far out of his head
knocks me out of the way
runs straight for the bed
rips the sheets off the bed
starts smelling the bed like a dog
i run and grab my passport whatever i
can find
and [__] leave half of my [__] there
and beat feet onto this street up in the
hills above papierte
and i'm just going like but she said she
loved me
and so now i'm in the quay in papierte i
check into some dg hotel turns out it
has like a transvestite disco in it and
i was really pretty blonde haired surfer
back then and you know and i'm basically
i had to barricade my door
and
and then i'm like i gotta go i'm going
back to la so i get back to la after
about a year away
and i i see my friends are basically
sitting
stoned in the same chairs i left them in
a year earlier
and i had kind of a moment of satori and
said like i'm out of here i'm never
living here again
and i'm getting as far away from this
[__] place as i can and so
hold on
that's a weird thing to have
because it seemed like
everything was kind i mean other than
this big french dude who kind of rolled
in on your dreams yeah but you know you
could find another tahitian girl or
another girl or i mean not one that was
sponsoring me oh that's cool that's true
so he was technically sponsored yeah
exactly
but
you get back to la okay so your friends
are still kind of stoned and they're
surfing or whatever but
it's weird it seems like that's an
extreme
viewpoint to suddenly have unless i
guess the connection that i just was
talking about where
people don't understand that what
they're doing now impacts their future
so that's probably what it was you made
this connection between oh
the i've been gone for a year and these
guys are doing the same thing and
they're gonna be doing that in five
years they're gonna be doing that in 10
years
oh what i'm doing right now is going to
impact my future so maybe you did make
that connection well also i had surfed
such good waves
and so many good waves i mean lennox had
back then light crowds the outer reefs
of cape iron you know big waves broken
head point every day
so that
i got back i was like okay i'm going
backwards now like i've done all this
and so i found this college of small
another extreme liberal liberal arts
school bard college and
at that time i think there were about
750 students
and they basically took your pulse and
saw that your check cleared and you
could get in
and so they had an immediate decision
plan so i flew back i'd been in la maybe
four or five days i found out about it i
flew to new york
i got in was it just timing-wise it
happened to be in the fall or whatever
whenever i got back
august yeah they had they had a rolling
admittance thing and it was basically
almost an art school
and in a remarkable place and it was up
in the woods of new york state
and uh i got really into hunting and
fishing
and so i just uh i fished i had a trout
stream on my college campus
and i fished and hunted every single day
and i had seven weeks off for christmas
so i'd go to the north shore every
christmas and then i'd go to scorpion
bay every summer so i'd work in the
unions make money and then go to
scorpion bay so i still got to surf a
lot but i became a pretty serious
student and it was not easy because i
was damaged goods because i hadn't done
[__] in high school so i was
like you said making up for these errors
and i was there with these you know
really privileged kids from the east
coast and like for example i had never
ever contemplated doing you know heroin
or anything like that the first time i
even heard about it was on the east
coast with the most privileged
children of america and
and it was horrifying to me and so i
became a very very serious student and
uh
and had some incredible professors and
wrote a really first-rate thesis on my
great-grandfather's time at nuremberg
before we get there it seems like you
had a moment of clarity also when it
came to uh the marijuana business yes so
you in the in the book tie sticks you
say the you get pulled over
and you say the officer took one look at
my bloodshot eyes caught a whiff of the
car's interior and asked son are you
transporting narcotics across state
lines
in that moment under the dark desert sky
i told myself if i got out of this jam i
would never put myself in this position
again although i continued to smoke pot
i never trafficked again so how how did
you get that how did you get through
that
um
you know tradecraft on some level i um
i had
you know it was like a half a pound or a
quarter pound
um and it was vacuum bagged and wiped
down with the gas or some solvent uh in
the cushion of the driver's seat and it
was a hatchback
mustang gt
and i'd been driving straight from la
and was all the way at the border of
texas and uh
and new mexico and i had two joints for
the drive and this was just for my
personal consumption in college because
there was no good pot on the east coast
and so um
so i'm smoking my second joint and i
drop it on the ground i turn on the
interior light i pass a cop going about
85 i don't even see him and i see you
know he lights so far back and say oh
that can't be for me and then i'm hit
with a spotlight and he's on the on the
pa going keep your hands on the steering
wheel and pull over to the side of the
road so i i'm rolling down both windows
the chichen chang shows going on and i
take a really long time to stop and so
and he walks up yeah no he said son yeah
he said there's a fruity herbal aroma in
the car and a brown stain on your lip
and and i just said
no sir that's all i would say no sir
okay i'm gonna have to ask you to step
out of the car
um
uh yeah do i have consent to search so i
gave him the keys hoping he would open
it without and he was too smart so he
said he made me give him consent and
then he started pulling my bags out and
one had a bunch of blocks of white
surfboard wax and up against the car and
he was sure it was like coke or
something so then he kind of and then
um he's going through all my bags and
then i have these bundles of slides and
brown paper with duct tape wrapped
around him up against the car and so he
gets two big buildups two strikes and
now we're like 20 minutes into it and
he's an american indian and uh
and
and then finally he's he's you know my
my seats are still folded down he hasn't
folded the seats up i have surfboards i
have all kinds of conversation all right
so he's asking me about this and we he's
kind of realizing okay this guy's not
that bad and then and then he says son
we're gonna strike a little deal i'm
going oh boy and he goes you're going to
keep it under 55 while you're in new
mexico and we're going to call it even
and that was the hardest part because i
was going to jump in his arms never do
it again i'm sorry officer
and and i really never did it again and
uh and that was that because i you know
i had i had made it over the rubicon you
know and i had turned my life around but
i almost [__] it up out of just you
know arrogance and stupidity you know
you track on any of the friends that you
had back from that arrow absolutely i'm
still friends with all of them for
better or worse yeah all of them saw
surfed with them in malibu yesterday
and you know that
some of them have been
you know real heavy lifters when it
comes to drugs you know like they should
take them to the mayo clinic and test
them because
from crack to fentanyl to and lost a lot
of friends to fentanyl
lost a lot of friends to opiates in the
last few years
so fentanyl
fentanyl is a fake
or a
man-made opioid is that what it is oh
yeah yeah
and it's what a thousand times stronger
than or something absolutely you know
the actual number how much stronger it
is
on the ratio but it's it's it's orders
of magnitude
and you know and it and it's in my
opinion asymmetrical warfare against the
united states by china
and so the chinese ship the chemicals
to the mexican cartels they make them
thanks to our poorest border
it comes across i mean we had where do
you get the the like
where's this theory come from that the
chinese are sending the chemicals to
mexico
it's it's fairly well known um because
they would get
american medical journals
that had
uh drug recipes that were too addictive
that weren't ever approved and and
whether it's
i don't see it as as like dr evil you
know with his pinky and his mouth coming
up but look at the impact that it's had
on america in
last year
more americans died than
108 000 americans died of ods so that's
more than korea vietnam and the war on
terror combined
and nobody seems to be too up in arms
about it is that in one year one year
or eight thousand yeah according to the
cdc as a parent that scares me more than
anything so the reason it scares you as
a parent because your kid can be at a
party and someone says hey you want to
take some ecstasy exactly and they take
x to c but it turns out being fentanyl
laced and they're dead yeah and that
happened in my town in north carolina
the kid was a sports star getting ready
to go to college
you know senior party let's take some
ecstasy and boof happened some naval
academy students right some naval
academy students in florida down there
partying i think a couple of them died i
mean just like a horror yeah it is and
and to me
you i mean
enforcing drug policies are difficult
but you know and then you look at like
purdue pharma
and how the opiate crisis came to
america
um
and the corruption i mean the that's at
our core
that's the nation's problem now is just
a a
a kind of corruption i saw in cambodia
and you know where you know pelosi's
husband's buying the stock that she's
about to approve or hunter's laptop or
this kind of stuff and it's a bipartisan
game i'm not you know um
i just
it's
you know and like we were saying prior
to the interview
everybody's in too deep with the chinese
to really call them out on anything
and
our
obsession with russia is conspicuous to
me compared to the blind eye we turn to
china
now with taiwan we're starting to firm
up a little bit
but that's sleep we're sleepwalking
basically and we're we're
you know foreign policy has public
relations
and and to have the same
neo-conservatives back
like you you know so succinctly talk
about um
i forget your exact phrase but you know
taking responsibility for your failures
and uh extreme ownership i think and and
we look at these foreign policy elites
that have just been wrong and wrong and
wrong
and
i've had moments where i got to write
for the big periodicals and stuff like
that but i always went too far and i
always i mean i i was all over soros's
guys during the 90s because they were
utopians oh the international criminal
court with universal jurisdiction it's
like well we kind of tried that in
woodrow wilson and it didn't work out so
well and
all those people went on to huge
positions you know ben rhodes samantha
powers these were cub reporters these
are my peers
and you know you played ball you got
tapped you got pushed to the head of the
class and so i was in the in the odd
position where i was critical of the war
on terror from a policy perspective and
thought it could have you know
particularly when it went to iraq
because
i had friends at the army war college
that i would call and say
what really impressive guy uh lieutenant
colonel conrad crane who was petraeus's
brain really and he was the author of
the counterinsurgency manual
and um you know and he said yeah tom
warwick from the state department who i
had argued with about war crime stuff um
he said he wrote the whole occupation
plan
they had like eight volumes and rumsfeld
said warwick state department chuck it
and so
people on the inside were nervous and
and kind of going like wow we don't
really know where this is going but it's
going
and
you know like
you know worse than a an error is a
blunder
and it's kind of blundering and well you
know yeah i i would say
worse than an error is
to not assess your situation exactly oh
yeah you know what i i was wrong about
this and here's the adjustments we need
to make now yeah and it took so long to
eat for any kind of that type of
recognition that it was ridiculous and
then libya and then syria and keep
rolling you know and now work this time
and by the way you know you can go all
the way back to vietnam sure you can
look at the ex it's just the exact same
thing it's the exact same thing in
vietnam
everything that was going on it's like
oh the generals only listen to the
politicians only listen to the generals
and the generals only listen to
themselves yeah and no no one's actually
talking to the troops on the ground that
know what's happening and could actually
devise a way to
move forward in a positive way doesn't
happen no freaking ridiculous
um all right so going back to
going back to it's a little tangential
discussions all good
uh going back to you so you end up in
college you go to this barred uh bard
college and you're
you're having a good time you you enjoy
it yeah
and you so talk to me about your your
master's thesis well or was it no it's
just an undergraduate okay and uh and i
won a bunch of awards so what was it i
was on the nuremberg trials and the
secret release of the convicted nazis to
trade to get german rearmament basically
the germans say the germans were
masterful you know and i mean statecraft
come on we're going to beat them and
they said oh you have to release our
prisoners of war if you want a german
army and now you know with the soviet
union
seeming to be menacing um in europe uh
berlin splitting
and and the germans are pouring gas on
it you know and so
uh
hit one of hitler's best spymasters on
the soviet union reinhard galen he took
all their records on the soviet union
and buried them and then surrendered to
the us and he said okay you want that
you get all my guys off the war crimes
list and
yeah we'll give you all the intelligence
you want on the soviet union so they
flew galen at al to the united states
and he would he would kind of hype up
the soviet threat to keep the americans
uh you know on their heels
and
and so the germans masterfully
manipulated us and we wound up freeing
some of the worst german war criminals
like some of the einsatz commandos
einstein's group and who followed the
vermont and were just pure executioners
and
and so
you know that was quite alarming when i
was younger i was a little
more idealistic um before i did field
work and uh
and so i then and it was an interesting
so that that became my phd advice
dissertation so then i went to columbia
to study with brigadier general telfer
taylor who was the chief prosecutor
scary guy
and um
uh there's gary in what way there's a
well he i think he argued i don't know
how many supreme court cases there's a
famous movie called the paper chase
about law school and john houseman is
this really yeah he he was john houseman
times 10.
and
and if you went off topic talking to him
he would just close his book up and say
i see we're finished today
and that was it you were dismissed
and uh you know and and old-fashioned
law school you go
jones
tell me about the smith act and you get
two shots the whole semester and if you
blow it
that's half your grade and so wait so
this is columbia law school well i i got
my phd in history but i also took
classes in law school and the school of
international affairs and had some
incredible professors and um
and it was horrible i hated every minute
of it i'm so glad i did it now
but it was uh
you know like being locked in a boxcar
for four years or something i mean what
was your vision at that time for your
life like what did you see yourself
doing did you want to go into journalism
did you want to be a professor what did
you want to do i thought i was going to
go to law school and then i i got my
masters in history i wrote another
thesis another went another step further
on nuremberg
and then i got into columbia law school
journalism school and history and they
they at that point you're kind of a
professional athlete so you get no
tuition you get money and all that in
the history and then i kind of pitted
them all against each other and i got
the best deal from history
um
and i was still not totally committed to
academia i just you know was getting a
free phd and i i really enjoyed it and i
was going to write a book and so i think
it was journalism more moving in that
direction but
but i
was always kind of a more active person
i didn't want to just sit on the
sidelines and then the opportunity came
as i finished to go to cambodia and it
was
what i wanted to do you know so how'd
that opportunity spring up um as i said
these two guys i grew up with in in
in california
were uh photographers for agency france
press they stumbled across the cache of
negatives at tool slang prison
and um they set up a secret dark room
and we're printing them and and really
preserving the original negatives the
evidence of of war crimes and that i i
knew that's the key
though
punishing the individuals is obviously
important but creating an empirical
record of the crimes
that's what's made holocaust revisionism
so difficult um because nuremberg
created an unassailable historical
record so that's where my mind was i
didn't think that they would ever try
anybody
and
it would and in fact they did and i
played a small role in keeping those
issues alive preserving the evidence and
passing that evidence on to the
cambodian
uh documentation center and i worked
closely with them as i went further on
and so what what year is this now so
this would be 94. um is my first trip
and then when did you go
side note when did you start training
jiu jitsu
i was training in jeet kune do first
with a guy named john peretti in new
york city who was a former pro-kick
boxer
um
and a real badass who fought on indian
reservations and was fighting
uh like mma matches in the tunnels
beneath chinatown and before the era of
closed circuit tv
he had um those asics tiger shoes and he
would sew steel toes in them and uh
and and
we get in all kinds of fights in new
york city uh and beat up bad people and
he encouraged us to do that and uh and
and and john donahue was
uh kind of around a bit at that time
and so i was you know i was training
with pretty a lot of kickboxing and he
was a real
a very brilliant guy an odd guy very
sadistic in his training everything was
live full contact and he would bring in
incredible fighters that he knew he
brought in a sumo wrestler um
igor zanoviev who fought amer beat mario
sperry we met him when he had just come
and he was fighting underground fights
um a russian fencer who was the fastest
human i've ever seen
only in one direction
and uh you know small arms stuff and all
kinds of different things um
and and we were all kind of scared of
wrestlers
and uh and peretti talked about fighting
this russian wrestler who almost broke
his neck and killed him in the first
round of their challenge match and then
he knocked him out so unconscious that
he thought he killed him in the second
round but that left a big mark so so he
never he encouraged us to finish our
fights on the hardwood floor
and uh and so we had no mats and um
and and
not many people lasted that long in that
school and uh
and then i heard about the garcia
brothers
the mexican guys the garcia brothers and
uh
and that was uh that was the gracies and
so then i had a friend uh who was a
college wrestler and he said oh yeah i'm
training with with hicks and gracie and
on pico and uh so you came back out to
california i come every summer so when
you spent your summer in california
you got to that's the first time you
went down to pico yeah i went first time
uh
i think 92 i got a private and then
hixson said come back you know come back
and really train and so then the next
summer i trained uh you know three days
a week in the men's uh
open men's daytime class and my friend
used to say it was it was lunch time on
the prison yard
and it was you know we had um this is
94. 95. uh no 93. 93. so this was eric
paulson yeah um
john lewis was in there as a white belt
um
and and as i said in the book like
they were minor compared like guys like
you then there was like prison
extraction unit guards that were so big
and the the gnarliest guy was a
offshore oil rig
like
a pipe joiner guy was like 300 pounds
and he would just grab a wrist and like
peel they just take things and uh
yeah paul vunik was in there
uh and then just
all the karaoke brazilian rio guys
coming here and coming there and and and
i surfed well and they knew me from
surfing so they liked that and i was a
good stand-up fighter so and we had to
do a lot of santa back then and luis
limau would put on these
these ridiculous leather boxing gloves
and
and i do my bruce lee stuff and they all
like kixin's kids thought it was the
best you know and uh
and um
and it was a great time you know and uh
and hicks and i became good friends
and not that deep but then
we both kind of had a pivotal moment in
both of our lives and it was
when i was going to start in cambodia
and he was going to fight in japan and
we would run into each other at sunrise
at malibu
and just there's hixson hey excellent
and we talked you know for an hour
and and i don't think i've had
any
superficial conversations with hixson in
30 years and it's always straight to the
guts of it and then
i started you know going to cambodia and
uh
a lot of times i would come straight
back from a gnarly trip
right to his house
always unannounced
in the same clothes i've been wearing
smelling like wood smoke and
kind of spun out on valiums and beers
and because you can't sleep after you
get that wound up right
and uh and he'd take one look at me and
he go
take off your boots
and uh he said let's play around a
little bit and he wouldn't even let me
start my show and tell and then i'd have
like a two hour private in in like
street clothes
and then he'd say okay like
what the [__] happened
on this one
and so and then i would tell them these
like these martial arts scenarios like
fighting on motorcycles i got attacked
on motorcycles once and uh and like had
a full 30 40 mile an hour fight on
motorcycles with three guys trying to
pull me off and we made them crash and
then
um a lot of mob stuff and as i was
saying earlier this is all in cambodia
yeah in cambodia like in
gosh i don't know i think about 99
they attacked the cambodian government
orchestrated mobs that attacked the thai
embassy and the thai ambassador had to
escape in a speedboat and any thai
business was ransacked by kind of
government orchestrated mobs icoms but
in plainclothes molotov cocktails
and
and as i was saying earlier i really
began to see the mob as this like
organic organism that you know feeds on
the sound of broken glass and the smell
of of fire and and they were all on
motorcycles and
they would the the military police would
come and disperse them and then you'd
hear them beep beep beep and they'd all
honk their horns and they'd reform up
and it went on all night and you'd hear
the beep beep beep and then and this was
my wife's first trip to cambodia so
you're bringing your wife on these trips
nah this was supposed to be a mellow one
okay yeah i said oh no it's mellow it's
not bad anymore and this springs up out
of nowhere and and this we were in the
capitol this time and i was not
expecting much
and um she goes oh look fireworks
i go those are tracers
and uh and so and it was a remarkable
thing um
you know that really stuck with me of of
and i i think
as a society
we're moving towards this point of of
you know this mob gets kind of the
military police heard them down this
narrow street
and so they're
they're like five abreast all on those
little motorcycles two or three guys on
the motorcycle
and they're kind of street punks right
and there's three military policemen all
hard old probably former khmer rouge
guys
dark skin which is
typically the you know the khmer rouge
guys are more peasant areas
and
and they block them off and they all
have aks old banged up aks
and they walk up and the the lead punk
and the lead cop go nose to nose and the
cot and that punk's going and then you
see and i'm on a balcony second floor
right above it
and uh
and the and the
lead cop plays really passive oh yeah
okay oh man i'm sorry and he and he
wheels around
takes two steps back nods to his guys
whips it around from the hip they all
open up 30 round magazines
foot over the heads of the
of the mob
reload those guys
leave their bikes
run each other over it turns into
complete keystone cops they turn into
the biggest bunch of cowards you've ever
seen in your life
and then i went out on the balcony and
started clapping
and
you know but um
yeah and i just i think uh yeah it was
had a profound impact on you know on the
mob and the cowardice of the mob when
someone has the courage to stand up to
the mob
what was the initial thread that you
caught onto for going to cambodia
was in my mind this was the worst
unaccounted for
atrocity since world war ii
this was the event that that destroyed
the never again promise that made the
whole never again
we're not going to be bystanders to
genocide
mythical and and i said
how and why did this happen
and that's what made me go that's why i
wanted to start there then bosnia
happened and then i'm in the foreign
correspondence club watching rwanda and
rwanda is just on a magnitude that you
know is like cambodia and so
these things are flaring up all around
us the un's sending
forces doing the same [__]
neutrality thing you had the french
foreign legion in cambodia generals lori
danna and reedu said unleashes war is
our business we'll go fight these guys
and they wouldn't take them off the
leash and both both generals resigned
um you had the aussie sas you had real
serious guys but they'd send the
bulgarians
they'd send
you know i mean the la most lasting
legacy of the un in cambodia was aids
because they took soldiers from all over
the world put them all over the country
and that was their and u.n land cruisers
that the khmer rouge all stole and they
would just steal them at at um
gunpoint and one of the guys that i
hired an ex khmer rouge guy he would
then sell them back to the un he would
be the negotiator for them to buy back
their own cars
and it was just weakness upon weakness
yeah you say in in facing death in
cambodia your book you say i began
research i began the research that would
make this book possible in 1993 i was
completing my phd dissertation at
columbia university on the nuremberg war
crime trials and laws of war the
dissertation was awarded honors but it
was cold comfort
i felt hollow and fraudulent like a
boxing commentator who had never been in
the ring i was writing about modern
conflict as a civilian leading a secure
life at an ivy league university
28 and a product of one of the softest
generations in american history what did
i know about conflict resolution beyond
what i had read
to teach undergraduates about how the
world should be without addressing the
rapidity changing the rapidly changing
world on its own terms was to perpetuate
a familiar cycle of fraudulence
so you were going to go get in it yeah
then so so as cambod the first time you
went to cambodia
like how much intel did you gather the
first time you went there
um
i saw that it was that the un had done
nothing about accountability i saw that
the
the evidence of war crimes and genocide
and all that was in the wind that you
know i mean we're finding stuff
you know from third parties i got a
bunch of material in east germany
because the east germans came in with
the vietnamese military
so
there was no
kind of it was catch as catch can so my
main imperative initially was to
preserve the historical evidence and i
was a historian with a background in war
crimes and so you know when i went to
telford taylor
and said do you think i should do this
he looked at me like were you
you know are you stupid what did you
study all this stuff for and my
grandfather when i went the pilot when i
went to tell him hey i'm going to go to
cambodia you know he said yeah great
don't be careful careful kills and so
nobody
in my family thought it was the least
bit strange you know
so
that you know my
dad's half sister marty hoy
would have been the first woman to climb
everest i think in 82
and her waist belton did and she fell
5000 vertical feet and they never found
her body and she was probably the
greatest female mountain climber of all
time
my uncle
sailed like a 29 foot boat from
ventura harbor
to the marquesas and spent like six
years sailing around the world so
we get it honest you know
and so i don't know you know it's just
as normal
now at some point um you know when
you're working the cambodia case
you you you start
pulling the threat on james clark lance
mcnamara mike deeds and crystal lance
yeah
and that's
tell us about those guys well i had
friends from the marijuana trade who
said hey
these guys we knew
vanished in cambodia and we never we
don't know what happened see if you can
find any records see if you can find
anything about them
and um
and
i found one of their pictures in the
prison white guy you know surfer and uh
and that was
you know that was something i could
identify with had i been 10 years old or
it could have been me i would have
probably done that at that time
so
that and then i met the families
you know and and that
i think and that's the thing also that
leads us into the miagues i don't want
to get too far ahead of myself but
nothing is more
damaging and traumatizing to a family
than having a family member disappear
and not knowing how what when
and not being able to tie that up and to
see
the
the trauma that the family goes through
as a result alcoholism suicide
all those kind of things you know really
followed a lot of the westerners who
were captured by the khmer rouge
how were these guys rolled up initially
sailboat just got too close and
those disputed islands
off of cambodia the vietnamese and
cambodians were always fighting over so
they had pete they had fat american fast
boats they had armed fishing boats so
they were
patrolling that stretch of water and uh
and and very vigilant about it and so um
yeah so that that was it and they just
you know got got their boats
took them in took them to tool slang
prison interrogated and tortured them
for you know
gosh the last two who died
you know it was days before the
vietnamese
uh liberated cambodia so
you know but they were three months or
something you know just
horrible tortures and and
rewriting their confessions over and
over and over and long 30 40 50 page
confessions
um and
you know and and that's the thing and
that's
you know you see that
at a certain point with torture it
doesn't work so
well
it's crazy that the
that the khmer rouge decided to
photograph everyone before they tortured
and killed them yeah did you ever
what compelled them to do that
they were so paranoid
that they had to prove to the leadership
that they were carrying out their orders
and the remarkable thing about that
prison is there were roughly like
1200 guards and staff members
something like 500 of them wound up as
prisoners
one guy screamed had a bad dream in the
night and screamed you're a cia
one guy broke
an ax handle your kgb
i mean
you know this is stone age communism
and
basically um
they're all spying on each other they're
all snitching on each other they would
have these meetings and and one guy i
interviewed uh who was one of the head
executioners named him hoy
and i was prepared to meet evil
incarnate and he was rumored to have
killed thousands with the with the ox
card axle to the back of the neck and so
i said um you know i'd be interviewing
him and a couple of marlboro reds and
tiger beers always kind of loosen them
up a little bit
and he said um
you know i said how did you how did you
get it tool sling prison he said well
i they showed up in my village you know
and you were drafted at gunpoint and i
ran away
and then i they came back to my village
i ran away again and the second time
they sent me to the front
in my first battle i was shot in the
head
and they said oh you're gonna die so
over the top you lead the charge he gets
shot a bunch more times he recovers from
that
um and then during the invasion of phnom
penh he gets a grenade dropped on him
and i say wow you know were you afraid
you were gonna die he goes no i was
afraid that i was gonna get captured and
they were gonna eat my liver in front of
me
so he crawls under a house survives that
and they say oh comrade hoy you're such
a valiant warrior we have a special job
for you and they send him to tool slang
so he starts out as a low level guard
then his boss is accused he becomes a
prisoner he moves up the food chain
and and so his superiors keep getting
killed so suddenly he's one of the head
guards he's driving the truck to the
killing fields at chennai
and
you know and i said something to the
effect of like do you feel bad about it
or some stupid question like that
and he just looked at me because it was
death either way
and uh
and you know and and it was
remarkable in that he
um
his whole life now is about penance and
you know because
i would say like these guys like oh do
you think it's important that pol pot is
tried and we hold him accountable and
all this rah-rah western human rights
[__]
and they would say
no not really at all i think they should
dig a big hole and bury all of it
because vengeance breeds vengeance and
that's very buddhist right but then they
would say
what does it matter he's he's 70 years
old he's only going to live 10 more
years he's coming back for 15 000 lives
as a cockroach
so he's going to get his
so their thing is you're reincarnated as
the as the lowliest horrible creature on
earth
for the next 10 000 years
so anything we can do in our earthly
time frame is is immaterial to them
so that was interesting you know that
really
and that the
the guy who probably had a bigger
more profound effect on me was
one of the
survivors a guy named chan
they kept him alive because he could
have carved effigies of pol pot i'm sure
he was a good artist yeah he was a good
artist i figured out that he was a good
artist yeah and
and i same thing first trip oh isn't
this great never again we're going to
get you justice
and and any kind of and he cracked and
he said you know what i'm only talking
to you because
the museum director told me to
and i don't like talking to you guys
and every time i talk to you you shorten
my life
i think that they should take all this
crap and dig a big hole and bury it and
tear down this prison
because vengeance reads vengeance
and then i turned off my tape recorder
said okay
see you later and i could have easily
spun that and gone
you know never again rah-rah-rah and
gotten a big check from george soros
um
but i really it put me on my heels and i
thought
what cold comfort that word
we're going to come in like the white
knights after the genocide and hold a
couple old guys up accountable
and at this time you've got rwanda going
on you've got bosnia going on i mean
during the former yugoslavian war
they're indicting people
with an ongoing conflict
where there's massive atrocities being
carried out and they're not even doing
anything rwanda the same east timor and
these are just blowing up all over the
place and the un's taking this very
passive
you know non-interventionist even when
they have forces on the ground they
don't take them off the leash and so
the whole thing
seemed very fraudulent to me i went to
the hague a couple of times and
um
you know and i and you know again i call
it the human rights industry it's an
industry
and when i started in the whole war
crimes thing i was one of about three
people nobody was in this field and then
it becomes this booming industry with
the hague with all these institutes and
places at different universities
and i've worked on a lot of these high
profile cases because i have subject
matter expertise
but
i can't take money or i'm a partisan
um so i've walked a strange line in my
career you know
where you know i worked on the jose
padilla the dirty bomber case i worked
on the david irving case i worked in the
khmer rouge case
and
you know and i s i've sort of uh you
know run afoul of everyone over the
years and it's funny because books are
like children
they make their own friends
so i thought oh the new york times the
polite society they're gonna all love me
no they hated me and uh
and it was
the professional military and the far
left
became my
best constituents you know and my first
book how was that
um
i'd
you'd have to ask me this is this is law
and war you're doing
war is an interesting book because
that took me 10 years to get published
and
it got rejected
by a lot of publishers
and i would get they take your book they
send it out to the experts in the field
and i would always get one really good
review and then one really bad review
because basically i said
nuremberg trials if anything
drew the germans together
in their defense of the third reich it
was the marshall plan it was economic
prosperity that's what converted them to
see the error of the third reich and the
error of the third reich the key players
are the children of the people who
lived through the third reich the 68er
generation comes of age and say dad what
did you do in the war
so that was would you say the 68 or
january yeah the 68ers is you know like
68 was a big year
of of strife in the united states oh so
people that were born in nigeria yeah
like the kind of lefties yeah and so
that generation that's when that society
began to reckon with its past it was not
in the 50s so that was a very unwelcome
message but then
a german historian a a guy by the name
of
jurg friedrich
he was one of my reviewers and he said
oh yeah of course we all know this this
is this should be published blah blah
blah
and then my second guy sent me the most
scathing criticism of anything i've ever
written
and and i
i and friedrich called me huh mcguire oh
great job blah blah i said it's done i'm
they i didn't get the contract he said
what and he sent he said send me the
guy's review so then he went through the
guy's review and ripped it apart and got
me hired by spiegel tv in germany so
then he introduced me to
hours
war crimes advisors the german defense
attorneys
floten richter otto kronz buehler who
was doughnuts and krupp's defense
attorney and this guy was adenauer's uh
special you know advisor on the war
crime stuff so in the treaty
restoring german sovereignty in the 50s
where they're kind of let off probation
in this gigantic thousands of page
treaty he inserts these paragraphs that
invalidate all the post-war war crimes
trial decisions the legal validity is
rejected
and
and i would no one would ever found it
out but he said look i wrote it in
invisible ink
i put the exception before the rule
no good lawyer would ever do that and so
that's
i had that in my book and that was not
happily received
so yeah so i was
so that was a difficult you know ten
years knowing that you're right but you
gotta fight and fight and fight
um and then the book got published and
yes that's the book that the military
liked in the left like but the polite
society sure
didn't like it but they didn't
they couldn't really come after me
because they hadn't done the heavy
lifting
like i said
their
analysis of the nuremberg trials never
went deeper than
uh robert jackson's opening address it's
this mythic myth of nuremberg as this
redemptive thing and so yeah
and then what about what about death uh
facing death in cambodia so that one get
received
pretty well actually yeah that one that
one i did better but still
and
i mean is the end what's your takeaway
from
you know vengeance breeds vendors is
that your takeaway
from that whole thing hey bury this
stuff in a hole and let's move on no
definitely not but i think what what
really came home for me was that
you have to talk to the culture that
that survived this that endured this you
can't come from the high and parachute
down from the hague and that's what they
did in cambodia and so when they finally
you know
they they took more time
to try for
80 year old khmer rouge leaders than it
took to try thousands of war criminals
after world war ii
and and you know i don't know how many
millions they spent the numbers are
impossible to tell
and and they got involved in what i call
therapeutic legalism which is we need
closure and healing and and you can't
ask a court to do that and then they
point to nuremberg say look look
nuremberg did that which is a myth
and so
to ask a court to do anything more than
punish the guilty and exonerate the
innocent is too much and so
all of this you know therapeutic
legalism and you burden it with with um
victims
units and all this kind of emotional
stuff and that's the world we live in
now where
you know this these notions of comfort
and safety and
i
um
i have a very
uh
kind of different view of it and i
believe that
that freedom isn't safe you know the
lamb's freedom's safe
if you want this kind of timid little
bleeding freedom but the lion's freedom
is a bold thing and if the lion breaks
its leg the hyenas get it and
that's the game you know so you don't
get it both ways
and i don't and i'm very uncomfortable
with the direction american society is
going now with you know this no and
that's why i don't teach anymore because
and i love teaching it was very fun
but it turned into this notions of oh
well you know
you know i don't feel safe i don't feel
comfortable i can't teach the holocaust
and khmer rouge and you be comfortable
what is that so i'm very socratic in the
way i taught and that
you know you don't raise your hand i
call on you
and uh and you know and that's keeps
them reading and keeps them on their
toes and uh i would walk in
when i taught at columbia with three by
five cards
and um
i'd say okay take one pass it down and
they kind of be giggling
and then i'd say fold it in half and
they go huh
arts and crafts i go write your name on
it i can't be bothered to remember your
name smith why are you here
smith
stock tips sports scores talk and just
boom fast and make them all talk and
just like you dealt with in buds
by the end of that first class they were
bound together as a unit in terror
and uh
and then and then you know
but then once
that class was over they go professor
maguire i go no it's peter
said that was a [__] show i said you
call on me anytime you need a letter of
recommendation
anything you know you survive man
i'm yours for the rest of your life
and
and i'm still in touch with a lot of
those students and they've done
incredibly well and i also also taught
jiu jitsu while i taught history and i'd
say any of you don't like your grade you
can come to the jiu jitsu class and you
can settle it with me on the mat how's
that sound
hey uh when you look at
uh the khmer rouge in cambodia when you
look at the nazis
the nazis had like a ramp up period you
know it took
1933 you could see it brewing there was
this sort of
slower boil as the things
started to transform
but the khmer rouge was like
overnight
madness
and madness at a level that's
it's
it's it's it's it's actual insanity well
it was class resentment that was stoked
and so you had an incredibly corrupt
you had the crazy king cena
who was you know just
this kind of wild playboy
um
an incredible decadent corruption of the
elites
um and the peasantry resenting them
already
leading really hard lives you know when
you go up in the cambodian provinces a
day seems like a week and it's hot and
it's just it's a hard hard life
and um
and so
you know they're seeing these very
westernized you know
decadent elites in the city and then you
have pole potting sorry kusampan and
these are all sorbonne educated
so and they bring the latest trendy
marxist theories and uh
and particularly mao
and and the cultural revolution becomes
you know the model
and they want the
blank slate clean peasants year zero
yeah they want people
you know most of the elites were you
know real
you know peasants with you know no
education nothing and they would get
them away from their parents and reshape
them
and um
and and that's what they did and they
did very quickly and they did it with
great chinese support
and denial on the western left who were
who were you know noam chomsky in
particular
um that you know would deny the
atrocities and cast a shadow of doubt
over what was going on when it was
pretty clear what was going on and then
uh
it was a very shameful period and then
it was shameful afterwards when
everybody knew and propped them up in
the name of cold war geopolitics
and so
um
yeah and then i mean so you have
in
you know in 79 you have the vietnamese
knock out the khmer rouge then the
chinese
knock take a run at the vietnamese and
they have a nasty little you know border
war for a minute there and then they
come to a truce and basically the
chinese are like you're not to talk
about the genocide okay
and uh and they gave the they
did a lot better than people
thought they would the vietnamese
vietnamese are pretty fierce
and um
and so
yeah and so that that was that was how
those the you know those cold war
geopolitics you know shape things up
all right so
when did when did uh when did facing
death in cambodia actually come out
2005.
oh said you were working on that for
you're working on that book for 10 years
10 years usually you're
yeah you're not a fast writer no no i'm
very fast but uh i had to let the events
play out hixon's book took me six months
okay there you go
um
so so that means where were you you were
in cambodia when 9 11 happened i was and
how what was that like
um it was surreal uh my buddy luke hunt
who
had just come from afghanistan and i
think he had interviewed mullah omar
and we were at the foreign
correspondence club it was late
and uh
and he was aussie and he runs up the
stairs world war three started world war
iii started and i was like i'll get out
of here and and i was kind of in denial
and i said oh you know it's just some
drunk and a cessna
and so i had a room i would keep at the
foreign correspondence club so me and
another reporter and luke went down
and were drinking beer and watching the
thing and all of a sudden the second
plane flew in and i went what the [__]
and then
then
the only thing i was right about was
when
all of a sudden the whole screen went
gray and i was like it pancaked
and i knew that from construction
because i'd seen controlled i'd seen
buildings collapse and things like that
because you know i've been around
construction my whole life and so
that uh
that's when it got real my wife was in
new york city and
uh so
it was impossible to get in touch with
her and uh we were on the upper west
side so we weren't quite near it
but um yeah that was
then i took me a long time to get back
and i was stuck over there and uh
yeah it was it was uh
surreal
okay and
so this book comes out 2005 facing death
in cambodia
that's received better yeah than law and
war yeah
um
and then
in the meantime you're working on this
uh on the greeno
advanced rescue craft yes so george
greenough who's like a
a legendary kind of iconic surf surfer
shaper
he's
kind of credited for the modern surfing
finn yeah
how did you how did you know him
um when i lived in australia uh and then
that's right you live next door
neighbors yeah and then i would come uh
often from cambodia
to uh
australia and so it was like the surface
the ptsd cure was
being
afraid of uh getting eaten by i mean
getting
you know killed by the khmer rouge and
then you go surf these outer reefs with
george green on have to worry about
getting eaten by
great white sharks and there were so
many sharks there at that and they still
are it's actually much worse now and
then and i had grown up on boats and
george always had these incredible
skiffs and he had won a 12-foot boat
he's an
amazing fisherman he caught
a 12-foot and a 13-foot tiger shark on
hand lines off his 12-foot boat
cut both heads off with a serrated bread
knife
brought them both in and uh you know
before it was before sharks became the
new dolphin we regularly fished for
sharks and didn't feel really bad about
it but uh but anyway um
i i fished with george a fair bit and
and i was living on the north shore i
had been a lifeguard and i was having to
make a lot of rescues in moklaia
and
the
north shore guy who does all the sleds
and rescue stuff taught me how to drive
a jet ski and i was like these things
suck and then i had friends in the teams
and they were telling me about all you
got to do is make this one yamaha suv
that we want because it's stable just
splash a mold off it and of course that
would have been too easy i don't do
anything easy i always have to reinvent
the wheel so i called george hey george
you still got the mold for the 12-footer
yeah yeah i do okay let's let's make a
jet boat and so
in the dirt under george's house
me and my old right hand man from
cambodia
cut the jet ski up and married it to his
12-footer and the first one came out of
the mold perfect
and then
we canceled
we cancelled a military program
and that
really
i didn't understand military contracting
things like that and then then we were a
big threat and
military-industrial complex stuff and
and it wasn't fun anymore
the military industrial conference will
conf will eat you alive yeah and ivan
was a great ally and we the teams loved
the boat the pjs actually became our
best
um our best clients because it was you
know c-130 drop before did you actually
start manufacturing them oh yeah yeah we
sold i think about 30 to the pjs but
then they made us
they didn't let us cut up yamaha jet
skis anymore that were perfect with
perfect wiring harnesses and gauges and
all that so we had to cob and a crappy
engine that they made us use and wiring
harnesses and steering and all that and
just it was like death by a thousand
cuts with nav c engineers and uh
and it was no longer fun at all but um
but i managed to get through it and came
in on time and on budget and delivered
the boats and then
sold my company to a company called
maritime applied physics and now it's
probably the best unmanned um craft out
there
and it's got a volvo penta and it's
super badass goes like 50 knots
now was it was the james clark lance
mcnair mike deeds crystal ants those
guys those surfers guys that were
captured off of cambodia
and imprisoned and killed was that sort
of the first thing that that
that the thread that led you to writing
thai stick yeah absolutely yeah and so
i found out about that
and i got more information
and i was at scorpion bay
and which is kind of like a you know a
smuggler's retirement home now and um
and
and it was unbelievable oh yeah i knew
him and you know all these people i knew
him i knew him and then
they kept saying you need to talk to
mike ritter you need to talk to mike
ritter you need to talk to mike ritter
and and i finally met mike ritter and he
had been a big smuggler in thailand and
what he didn't tell me was that he had
been contracted to supply their load
and so
he so he had been
contracted to to bring them their load
of pot from
from thailand yeah from trot so those
guys were on a boat
sailing to thailand yeah they were going
to link up yeah and mike ritter was
going to give him a little pot yeah
bring wherever probably back to the
states yeah and ritter was a surfer from
santa barbara and he would go on a thai
fishing boat
with you know usually no compass they'd
give them the crappiest boat they had
because they didn't want to get it
seized and he'd have one of those
truffle log spinners
and you know just old-fashioned
navigating and he'd bring the pot out
and you know pirates and i mean
that's that period of time is the worst
period of piracy in world history this
is what years this is in the 70s late
70s yeah so well mid delays yeah vietnam
falls in 75 so you have all those
vietnamese going out to sea with all
their worldly possessions usually in
women's jewelry that's how they carry
their wealth so you had the most feral
brutal pirates you could ever imagine so
that was a very dangerous piece of water
and uh and so that's what ritter was
doing for for many many years and living
in thailand and
he was one of the first guys to surf
garage again
one of the first guys to surf bali so
you had a bunch of smugglers in bali in
the off season
and basically grudging was founded by
pot smugglers
and so they were the ones who really
were the first to really kind of explore
the indonesian archipelago
and um and that was you know ritter was
one of them and so then i trained him as
a historian
and then he started interviewing his
sources of old retired smugglers and
we
made sure we
interviewed people who had been busted
so there was at that time no double
jeopardy
and then things got a little wobbly
after 9 11 and uh
and um and then i was going to find the
old khmer rouge guys and you know
different you know people on that side
law enforcement confidential informants
um there were a lot of old us
intelligence guys involved because you
know they had they had the knowledge of
thailand and they had the insurgent
areas of thailand was where all the pot
was grown so they had worked those
insurgent areas during the vietnam war
how long did it take you to write thai
stick ten years
but that was a thousand hours of
interviews we did
yeah what do you think the value of the
trade the pot trade coming out of that
the surfers brought into america
well i mean at that time it was great
but but ultimately it's it's basic adam
smith economics
it becomes too expensive to transport it
the lows get too big i mean we're
talking about like
20 30 ton loads
um and then
it drives the industry to the united
states
california is growing the best pot in
the world so people are like why don't
we just grow it in mendocino or you know
trinity or one of those counties
um and so
so there's no the money's gone and so
that's ultimately what happens in 88
that's where there's there's a bunch of
huge busts and the the biggest guys kind
of go down and then nobody wants to
bother with it and that's it it just
implodes yeah exactly yeah
now at some point during this you you
you got another book um that you're
working on right now
um well i guess before we get to that
you got you did right end up writing
breathe you wrote the kicks in book yeah
and you kind of kind of got into that a
little bit but what was the what was the
spark how did you convince hixon that he
needed to write a book
um
we had been talking about it for a long
long time
and
he and i talk a lot and and like i said
and then it's never light and uh
and there's a lot of stuff i know that
he doesn't know and there's a lot of
stuff that he knows that i don't know
and we always were friends and i was a
jiu jitsu skeptic i was not for how many
minutes
well i wasn't it wasn't that it didn't
work in a one-on-one situation but but
in the worlds i was in i loved it as an
exercise thing i loved it
for the friends i made by going and
beating these terrifying guys and then
being nice and not humiliating them and
making them into students
and made some of my best friends around
i mean i fought guys in west australia
canada maine
cambodia always with the like well that
wouldn't work on me and you know how it
goes from there and uh the skeptic yeah
for three minutes yeah so i was like
john the baptist of jiu jitsu for a
minute there because i was just had done
it early
but i didn't like keys
and i didn't you know there were just
pieces of it i didn't like i liked
striking i was confident striking i had
some very
patented entries that were kind of like
you know
i i don't have a politically correct way
to say it but um
the lunging special needs person and uh
the drunken monkey exactly just like
what no it was what what what and then
close the distance and so
you know so i i you know again
and i would throw this stuff at hixson
uh come on hixson like yeah yeah try to
yeah try to disarm me with this knife
like because i learned the fencing from
the russian guys and they're so fast
you're not they're not doing this
they're doing that and uh
so
you know we really kind of explored this
stuff for a long long time and in a very
honest way and we're really good friends
through a lot
through his son's death and you know i
knew his son well and uh
and so um yeah he just finally i think
the covid year everybody with things
were going slow and that's how we got
going
well i mean that was a that's a
fantastic book you and you hit the new
york times bestseller list yep yep
whether they liked it or not no hicks
and hixson did
boy we got the worst review i've ever
had in my life in publishers weekly and
it was you know toxic masculinity gone
wrong and it was classic i loved it
oh wow yeah it was bad i wrote a novel
called final spin and
publishers weekly gave me a great review
and it was pretty awesome and my my
editor like sent it to me he goes i
can't believe this they compared me to
uh david mahmet wow and just like oh
this you know bought and my my publisher
was like
dude this is insane that they gave you
this incredible review and i was like
well it's not that insane bro it's an
awesome book
but uh but yeah the the thing the thing
that was cool about it was i know that
publishers weekly they don't play around
like if they're coming at you they have
no problem just trashing your book if
they don't like it so they didn't like
breathe oh i hated it but it was great
and there was like nobody should be
interested in this book there's only
martial arts deviants or something to
that effect and uh and then it was
bestseller a week later
uh
tell us a little bit you you mentioned
this quickly you got the fainting robin
foundation which is a non-profit that
you have the title the name of the
foundation comes from an emily dickinson
poem
um which is if i can stop one heart from
breaking i shall not live in vain if i
can ease one life the aching or cool one
pain or help one fainting robin unto his
nest again i shall not live in vain
meaning that if you can help someone
that's really not in a position to help
themselves
that's going to be a positive thing
absolutely what what inspired that from
you um i was watching
my professions disappear
journalism number one
um the internet really killed a lot of
of our careers you know we went from
you know getting paid per word royalties
every time something was published to
flat rates and just it goes on the
internet it's gone forever
um well i mean i kind of look at like
that's because i'm on the other side
right i'm like the r i'm from the people
yeah yeah you know we have a podcast
i remember i went to we had we had this
podcast for maybe six months or
something and i went and got interviewed
on
mpr
and uh
so i roll into this mpr interview is in
new york city
i go into a full-on studio there's six
or seven people behind the glass pane
there's two people in the room then
there's the person that's interviewed
it's massive like this massive
production i mean as you can see like
this is the we're sitting in our in our
recording studio right now which is
literally a converted closet this used
to be the maintenance closet at victory
mma in fitness we eventually made it a
little bit bigger than it used to be
but i go in there and so then i go you
know
like how many people listen to you know
how many what's the audience of your
show because i was talking to the guy a
little bit afterwards and he gave me
some number and it was some
not big number and i was like dang
here's
me and echo charles with a thousand
dollars worth literally a thousand
dollars worth of equip how much you
spend when you first bought the gear
yeah one thousand a thousand dollars
worth of equipment and our audience was
at least 20 literally 20 times as big as
theirs yeah yeah and i'm thinking this
is kind of awesome oh yeah here's these
people they went to school and they got
promotion and they're paying they're
paying people to listen to
advertisements going out all this stuff
all this hype and we're sitting in here
in a closet
with a thousand dollars worth of
equipment our audience is at least 20
times bigger than theirs
so
i support the downfall of journalism
yeah so tell me your take what am i
missing well it it as much journalism
it's uh academia and because i was also
a professor and that
are you gonna make me attack the
academic profession now too
i'm happy to help um but know that
you know i basically was making less
money
as a
professor with three two books three
books ivy league phd that i made as a
construction laborer without a high
school diploma at 17 years old without
adjusting anything for inflation and so
what we've seen in academia is that
the money's gone to middle management so
every special interest group now has a
commissar that they go to who advocates
for them and the student is a customer
now
so that's completely explain to me the
commissar in the middle here how's that
taking money out of this professors well
because
professors salaries um have dropped 10
years disappeared to make way for this
managerial class
and so the managerial class you know
will
typically when i first started
i would be the assistant dean for a
semester it was always a professor now
you have people who are neither scholars
nor teachers
and this is this
you know i have a phd in education
come on you know you can teach you can't
teach i can't teach you how to teach
and
it's as much an art as it is a science
and uh
and it's depressing frankly and i don't
want to be around it it's it's not
um
there's just there it would yeah that's
a whole that's a whole big ball of wax
but um i was going to college when i
went to college when i was 28 years old
because i had been in the military in
the military sent me to college i was
going to the university of san diego and
i was in class i had an english
professor super nice professor super
cool i was an english major
and she said at the beginning one of
these classes so i'd been in the navy i
enlisted the navy when i was 18 years
old and so i'd been in the navy for 10
years at that time
and
the professor you know was kind of
saying hey listen you know here i am i'm
a tenured professor i
i have a phd in literature blah blah
blah i went to this school in that
school
and she goes and yeah i can't afford a
house in san diego
and so i'm sitting in the front row
which i always did i said the fro roll
of every class just looking at the
professors just like no one else cared i
would line up my pens like in case i had
a pen go down i'd be ready with a
secondary and so i'm sitting there in
the front row and i would i would over i
guess i was being a little bit uh
abrasive a little bit abrasive but but
the teachers usually love me because i
was like the i would the most fully
engaged student they probably ever had
in their lives so i'm sitting in the
front row she gets done with her tirade
and i just raised my hand you know
straight up in the air and she's like
and this when i went to college was the
only place in in my life that they
called me john because that's what was
on the roster because my real name is
johnson they call me john i never
corrected him because i didn't care so
she she says you know yes john and i
said
how how long did you go to school
for and she goes well it was total i
think it was the total was ten years you
know to get her up that you know this
this this i said how much did that cost
you
and she said you know whatever it was
380 000 or something like this
and i said well hey
i said i enlisted in the u.s navy when i
got done with high school
and i've been working that whole time
and i have not one house in san diego
but two
and she was so
she was so frustrated with that
statement but it's kind of true because
you know she literally spent two that
was what my first two houses in san
diego cost i guess they cost a little
bit more than that but
that was around what the first two
houses i bought in san diego
so
you know that academic thing
and
i mean the academic world just seems to
be
have gone it's gone insane am i wrong
absolutely right and and the thing is
and i've seen this for a long time and
spoken out against it for a long time
i'm a first amendment absolutist
i believe anything short of that is
sophistry
that this group gets this level and you
you know and then we come back to to
comfort and safety and psychic
damage and this and that and oh you're
you can't
you know criticize this group
because of the psychic damage you're
inflicting this and that once you go
down that road you're you're in
sophistry lane and i don't want to play
that game and so
um
yeah it's just everyone my friends who
are still in academia
walk on eggshells and
you know they have to
watch out for the cultural commissars
because you know then you have this kind
of
star chamber courts
where
the student goes to
one of the many deans and says
that he looked at me in a way that made
me uncomfortable and my responsibility
you were born uncomfortable i can't help
you with that and your level of comfort
and my level of comfort aren't the same
so then the professor is accused without
a hearing
without knowing who his accuser is
so there's no due process i mean one of
the cases my foundation looked into was
an anatomy professor named michael
michael shively he taught for 30 years
at utah valley university
the president of the university's son
university's
uh what was it nephew
kind of instigated a a crusade against
him because he was
um his classes were too hard
he didn't put things up on the
right
um you know uh blackboard
you know sort of computer thing
and um
and they couldn't really get him on
anything and again he didn't know who he
was accused by he didn't know what he
was accused of
and after about six months he started
losing his mind and he blew his brains
out and
and then the family sued the university
uh it came out that it was you know that
the president of the university
intervened on behalf of her nephew
it went all the way to the 10th circuit
court of appeals
now their attorney is going for a rid of
cert to try to get the supreme court to
take it up
but these are
increasingly common situations where you
are accused of something
and you don't get to defend yourself you
don't know who your accuser is and this
is a real violation of due process and i
mean i had a situation where i had a
female student come and say oh well i
was uh
i was uh
i couldn't do i've been missing the
classes or something because i was
sexually assaulted i said okay that's
very serious
i said let's i know the u.s attorney and
like
let's do it you know if you you got to
think this through if you want to you
know go
really do this you go to the u.s
attorney you don't go or with the d.a
in town you don't go to some academic
bureaucrat that will pollute the case if
you want to go after this guy oh well
i'm not sure i'm not sure i said well do
you think about it let's talk about it
tomorrow i go to the head of my
department i say hey
this happened
i told her she needs to go to the
authorities if she's serious about it
she said no no she has to go to the
title ix group and the this which is an
in-house university judiciary and i said
no i don't i don't agree and i
i'm not gonna do that and i'm on one
semester contract so what do you got on
me and i liked my department head and i
didn't you know want to make trouble for
but then i met with a student the next
day i said okay come on let's
get into the brass tacks of this because
if you do go down this road of
litigation and all that you're going to
get your past pulled out it's going to
be serious
and
i said was there alcohol involved yeah
um okay and so anyway turns out
she drank too much passed out on a couch
at a friend's woke up and there was one
of the roommates had come in and was
standing over her
and and you know that could have ended
this guy's career it could have been
incredibly problematic and he wouldn't
have known what he was accused of by who
oh that was the extent of what it
happened that was what had happened
and so
you know
again these things need to be heard out
you can't just take you know every
man is guilty every woman is always
right
life is more complex than that i mean i
saw professors that married students
that are still married so i don't have a
kind of childlike view of life i treated
my students as adults
and i talk to them like adults and i
talk to them about their futures and
you know i would say every student would
have to come and meet me in my office
and people would say oh don't ever close
your door with a female student
so
why i'm you know i'm married i'm not
like
your students are like your kids
and uh
and i would say what's your major
what do you um what's your major what do
you want to do what do your parents want
you to do and how much student debt you
have
almost every one of those kids would say
no one's ever asked me that in my career
thank you so much no one
they've tried to sell them into a new
program oh we got this new graduate
certificate and i was like a what
a certificate i said is that a master's
no it's a certificate i said that's a
[__] scam
and uh and so
and i said are they paying for you to
get this certificate oh no i gotta pay i
said well
is the professor
that's telling you to do it in charge of
this certificate program hey how'd you
know i was like man you're getting
hustled and uh
and so it's a business now and because
the universities are competing with each
other
you know to get students they're
spending huge amounts of money on
gyms and
vegan food bars and you know
uh
just really ancillary stuff yeah you
know when i look at it
if you can get if you're going to learn
something of value if you're going to be
actually educated
great
knowledge is power and you can if you
can go to go to some
event or some school or some university
and you're gonna learn something you're
gonna walk out of there and say oh i
know how to do this thing now
more power to you great
but yeah if you're in there and you're
spending money on something that has no
value other than the paper that it's
printed on then it's it's kind of
worthless and i don't know that
i i think that
a lot of times the way the
what what people are taught isn't really
a usable skill and especially the way
it's taught isn't really a usable skill
and i mean this happens with leadership
you know a lot of there's there's
universities that offer some kind of
leadership training but it's not
actually leadership training they don't
learn any leadership from it they learn
some
weird abstract theory about leadership
but they don't know how they don't learn
how to lead
it's like if you went to college to play
to play guitar
and they never gave you a guitar to play
you wouldn't know how to play when you
got done you'd be able to talk about it
a little bit but you wouldn't be able to
do it and i see a lot of programs that
are set up like that where they're
teaching you a lot about the guitar and
you learn some theory about the guitar
and you know what a guitar looks like
but you know how to play that guitar so
basically what you learned
has almost no value so you know for
leadership for me you know
the reason i know this because i i teach
leadership and we teach leadership to
people that have gone through big
programs and they don't they'll tell us
like oh i learned more in the three days
i just spent with your company about
leadership infinitely more so not even
close to what i learned in my two-year
you know master's degree or my mba they
they just don't they're not doing it in
the same way so and i think that that's
kind of become the standard sure the
standard is oh well we can teach you
about the guitar and we can teach you
about the the music theory and they can
teach you about a bunch of different
guitars we're gonna have a bunch of
different guitarists come and talk to
you
we're gonna have the best we have eric
clapton come and talk to you and tony
naomi it's going to be great
and that is cool sounds cool right but
you still don't know how to play guitar
right so we like to get them playing
that guitar right right get on that get
box but you're playing a high-stakes
game in your
view of leadership that there's actually
something on the table well yeah yeah i
mean i teach businesses i mean sure the
vast majority of clients i have now are
look we teach law enforcement we teach
military absolutely but we mostly teach
businesses sure business leaders now
business leaders actually do have
something real at stake they got jobs
they got capital they got safety there's
for sure this is all really important
stuff
um
but it is derived from the highest of
consequences sure
without question
and so because of all these
changes
um
good and bad
maybe mostly bad some definitely good
because like i said it's good that echo
charles and i could sit in this room
with a thousand dollars worth of
equipment and talk to way more people
than npr yeah in a lot of cases um
you made the fainting robin foundation
so the the
the mission is to help out
people that
need it yeah and it grew like it started
out
professors
journalists
and and journalists pushing the envelope
right the real
guys like ed villame who
you know was british newsman of the year
testified in the hague found the serb
camps in bosnia um the people that are
outliers that are you know coming into
the later parts of their career and you
know have really put it all out there
but isn't it kind of cool now that you
can do that with no without being part
of the mainstream media at all
i mean there's there's plenty of people
out there that are publishing i mean i
know you have a sub stack sure stub
stack i love subscribe
you know that's a way that you can go
and you can get published and you can
publish your stuff you can get out there
and you don't have to worry about that
and say whatever you can say whatever
you want yeah um but then it grew
into helping those who can't help
themselves like a lot of veteran
outreach
um your generation of veterans
did more heavy lifting than
you know really any generation i would
say in american history with the
multiple tours with
um
a lot as was asked of you and i am
living in north carolina there's a lot
of veterans and
having a hard time finding their way
after their their time in the service
many of them and simple things helping
them find jobs helping them do things
like that more complex things getting
them off ssr
eyes and
the you know meds and stuff like giving
out those things like candy yeah do you
see this track in this most recent stuff
that they're saying that uh depression
isn't from a chemical imbalance anymore
yeah it doesn't work this is like a big
lie yeah like a 30-year lie have you
heard the cyclotrols
so they used to say oh you're depressed
okay it's because you have a chemical
imbalance in your head take these drugs
and they'll make you feel better right
and now they're saying
uh actually no it's not a chemical
imbalance it's just like how you're
feeling and drugs
aren't going to help you in that in the
way that we were saying they were which
is really freaking disturbing very
horrible and particularly the side
effects
um that's very disturbing yeah the side
effects are crazy and the side effects
too that
even when you read the fine print
about what it's going to do to you
there's finer print that says like oh
and by the way if you come off this at
this rate or you mix this with that it's
going to make you have literal suicidal
ideations like it's crazy yeah yeah it
is and that i'm and hixson and i have
been talking a lot about that and uh
and finding you know natural ways and
i've been this is some of the things
i've been doing but also doing kind of
more direct action stuff like a woman
a friend of a friend in santa barbara's
sister was murdered in cambodia
we launched an investigation and it took
us about eight years but captured the
guy
um
another guy the old pot smuggler who did
a double life got double life and a
billion dollar fine was a big smuggler
but all pot
and um
and he did yeah 27 years for a
conspiracy he was not part of what and i
you know i read these things all the
drug conspiracy oh yeah yeah and uh he
got out he got a presidential pardon
last year and we were lobbying for that
um
so things kind of i'm almost like the
last resort when everything
every other
avenue has failed they wind up at my
doorstep and i can't take all of them i
mean i basically work for my kitchen
table
with no office and but it's is
remarkable what you can do through
persistence and uh
and i have persistence
[Music]
you're you're a one book a book a decade
writer you've got definite persistence
so there's a we got this thread of your
of your writing
and it's the thread that you pull
through so you know you had the
nuremberg trials this thread kind of
leads to war crimes this war crimes
threat leads to cambodia the cambodia
thread you you find the surfers that got
rolled up and tortured and killed that
thread leads to tie sticks
there's another thread that
that is something that you're working on
now
and that's the battle of cotang
which happened
at the end of the vietnam war
and the khmer rouge
seized
a u.s merchant ship the mayaguez
and
there's this whole thing unfolds so the
so the marines go they recapture the
ship but they also assault the island
there's a little island uh where it
looked like the the crew of the of the
myguys had been taken
and so the marines do an assault on this
island well this the island is
it's run by the khmer rouge there's
khmer rouge elements on there
um
the
they didn't know it the marines didn't
know it at the time but the crew wasn't
on that island at all and they'd
actually been released and returned but
they didn't know they're already in the
air they go
and assault this this island and
i'm actually gonna you you gave me like
a kind of it's sort of a draft your
proposal you're working on it
but let me just read a little chunk of
this this is your latest project it's
going to be called left behind
and again the thread is how did you get
onto the story you met someone that was
on com
you met a cambodian i met khmer rouge
yeah that was on kotang yeah island and
fought against the marines yeah
absolutely this is what opens up this
story for you and you also started
hearing
about you were you were tracking on the
americans that were in s21 the pr the
prison yeah
and you were hearing that there might
have been other americans and where were
these other americans and so you pulled
the threat on this yeah let me go to
this little section here
from his trench near the east beach m
som and this is the this is the
cambodian soldier that you
met yeah so or sorry khmer rouge yeah
one of a number um msalm
watched knife 23 that's a helicopter the
next chopper attempting to land fly
straight toward him this one had a big
propeller on top and a small one for
steering said psalm he shouldered his
rocket and waited until it was 50 meters
away and in his crosshairs i aim for the
head and hit the tail he recalled
the helicopter's tail broke off with an
audible snap and now the rudderless
ch-53 shuttered spun and crash-landed on
the beach all 25 americans on board were
able to escape from the wreckage and
find cover
soldiers in stretchy robes jumped down
said psalm there was exchange of fire
now due to clouds of thick dust and
smoke from the gunfire the khmer rouge
commander could not even see the beach
and took a moment to pray to buddha for
help i had been fighting all my life but
the fighting on kotang was really
terrifying
the initial assault on the island had
been a debacle in less than one hour the
u.s had lost three helicopters and
eleven men
the young marines who had been training
in okinawa less than 48 hours earlier
were now experiencing combat for the
first time all alone at seven at only 7
20 a.m the longest day of their lives
was just beginning
unbeknownst to the americans and
cambodians now fighting on kotang
minutes before knife 21 landed on the
island khmer rouge radioed announced
that they had freed the mayaguez and her
crew even worse the prisoners were not
and had never been
on the island
al bailey was standing waist deep in a
khmer rouge latrine almost out of
ammunition fighting for his life
he was happy to see jolly green 43 the
big sikorsky hh-53 search and rescue
helicopter approached the land
the young marine was even happier when
he saw his six foot two 250 pound
sergeant fofo sergeant t
and you say that uh tula
tutely
sergeant sergeant t toutelli
walk onto the beach with mortar rounds
exploding around him like a comic book
superhero
sergeant t stepped out of the helicopter
and was like let me get this [__] under
control it was a walk in the park to him
he was ready to conduct business
recalled bailey he was a like a pissed
off parent who had just found someone
had abused his kids
born and raised in american samoa
man how do you say his first name fofo
okay just leaving it you gotta you got
the full name here fofo my tugali
something like tula gali
uh
tuatelli better known as fofo moved to
hawaii at 10 and joined the marines at
18. he spent his first tour in 1967 as a
scout sniper hunting vietcong in the
jungle during his second tour he fought
in chulai khesan in the battle of hue
and was awarded two presidential sites
unit citations for extraordinary heroism
and a bronze star
after tootelli's request for a third
tour was denied he became a platoon
sergeant with 2nd battalion 9th marines
and had been training al bailey squad
when he received word that training was
over and that he would be leading them
into combat for the first time although
the soft-spoken samoan treated his men
well he'd made quite an impression on
his charges in okinawa when he broke up
a fight between a black and a white
marine by placing each of them in
headlocks
he shouted marines don't fight marines
fofo smashed their heads together
and knocked them both unconscious
nobody and i mean nobody ever challenged
him said bayley this man had killed iraq
of vietnamese you could see it in his
demeanor the way he carried himself
when sergeant t spotted his marines
clumped together on the west beach he
ran toward them shouting what the [__]
are you guys doing calm the hell down
and listen
fofo worked his way up and down their
line giving orders and words of
encouragement finally he turned to
bailey and said only fire when the
helicopter comes in don't waste ammo
watch the trail any of these bastards
cost cross the trail blow their ass away
then he grabbed his m16 and said i'm
gonna take care of this machine gun
problem no shooting until i get back and
vanished into the jungle
fofo walked carefully into under the
canopy until he heard an incoming
american helicopter then he stopped and
listened the samoan saw some branches
move then he spotted two bare-chested
cambodians with red checkered scarves
around their heads adjusting a big gun
when they began firing at the helicopter
he shouldered his weapon but could not
get a clear shot because the foliage so
he walked all the way to the edge of the
machine gun nest and opened fire
by the time fofo had emptied his one
magazine
one magazine one khmer rouge soldier lay
dead and another was wounded but still
alive rather than reload the marine
picked up a nearby machete hacked the
wounded man until he stopped moving then
grabbed their ak-47s cigarettes canteens
and sandals
as he worked his way back toward the
west beach he saw another occupied
bunker opened fire and ran towards it by
the time the samoan reached it the
bunker was empty but a fire was still
burning a pot of rice cooking and there
was fl a fresh blood trail leading into
the jungle
so
this is some serious scrapping that
these guys are going through
and
uh
just going through some of the events
that took place by z by zero 700 there's
109 marines on the island
three of the helos there was eight helos
used in the assault
three of them were destroyed
on the insert
um between 0 900 and 100 100 additional
marines
had been landed on the island
nine had been wounded and those guys had
been evacuated which meant there was
about 225 marines on the island
they make they're fighting throughout
the day they make multiple attempts to
extract the marines they drop at 1800 at
night they drop a freaking blue 82
massive bomb
it's they call it a daisy cutter i mean
it's just a massive
bomb it creates a mushroom cloud it's
huge
after dark they finally start to get
extracted they're loading helos under
fire
uh they leave dead behind
they also leave with a false head count
meaning
they think that they have everyone but
they don't
they finally get back on the ships
you know and now they do a head count of
a legit head count and they they figure
out that they're missing uh lance
corporal joseph hargrove pfc gary hall
and private danny marshall
and then they received uh a radio
transmission
from those guys like one of the aircraft
circling overhead receives a radio
transmission
saying hey swim to sea and we'll we'll
get you
and they respond to only one of us only
one of the marines could swim
effectively enough to actually swim to
sea
and and these guys get declared missing
in action
um
on july 21st 1976 those were changed to
killed in action
the way it turned out
joseph hargrove was captured pretty
quickly he had a leg wound and then a
week later and you go through the
details even in this i don't want to you
know obviously you're going to put a
whole book together on this that we'll
have to we'll have to cover on the
podcast and i hope we can get fofo in
here to get it done
that's the plan
um
you know because i i know there's and
you talk about it here but
he was he he received the navy cross
is that correct no he did receive
he got uh uh
it was interesting because
on
it's the marine
it was a very lower metal and i had a
general look at the whole paperwork and
the secretary of the navy had signed it
and he said the only reason the
secretary of the navy would have ever
even seen this
was
because he was either up for the navy
cross or the congressional medal
so one of the
one of the lieutenants got the navy
cross
for doing nothing close to what fofo
totally had done
um
and
and even one of the things i've been
trying to do is get them the vietnam
service medal and tulsi gabbard and mark
meadows had tried to do it in 2016 and
um the official government position was
well you know the uh
the vietnam war ended when the paris
peace agreement was signed in 1973.
so this isn't the vietnam war
i mean their names are on the wall
so it's it's a very strange case and i
think there's institutional
embarrassment
as i demonstrate there there's also
knowledge that those men were left
behind and i think
what's motivated me on this case is is
how heavily that's weighed on
those marines and those who knew that
and were ordered not to talk about it as
well
and so
um i spoke at their reunion this uh
last may and um
you know this is something that you know
many of these guys have been back to
cambodia they've met with them som
they've pleaded with him where are their
bodies and you know and i i uh they
they've sent the pow mia guys from camp
smith there to do the the mitochondria
dna
um
and it's
you know i think that the ford
administration acted very badly
i think that they already had it planted
on the new york times as america is back
and that was that was you know the
height of our impotence
so this is may 15 1975. this is two
weeks after the fall of saigon
yeah that's one thing that makes it so
and again that you've got some of the
details even that that i read here just
you you're used to this kind of
incompetence in vietnam now by you know
the generals the politicians mcnamara
lbj like you're just used to this
disgusting
lack of ability to make decisions and
lead and not be influenced just by raw
politics on a daily basis just
disgusting yeah and then
but what's interesting about this this
is like one incident and since it's a
little bit separated
and you've got a different
administration you go oh it's the same
incompetence and you just see these
decisions getting made and these
cover-ups are happening it's just gross
yeah it's gross and of course it's the
freaking men on the ground the marines
that pay to pay the ultimate price for
these horrible decisions i mean you got
a section in there about the seal
commander yeah an amazing guy yeah who's
like this is total [__] he's calling
it good for him
um
yeah tom coulter and he basically you
know faced down the admiral and said
okay i'm gonna leave room
on the front of my zodiac for you and
your officers and you can go on that
island with me and they were not honest
with him either and they said oh we want
to drop leaflets and this is kind of you
know
they had the lithographer aboard
one of the navy ships print 10 000
cards cambodian french and english
saying
bring all the americans to the
helicopter wreckage including the dead
ones
so that does lead you to believe they
knew that these guys were behind i i
left behind i have no doubt they knew
and um
and again it was already on the cover of
the new york times and the press attempt
and you know the pictures of kissinger
and rumsfeld and ford in tuxedos smoking
cigars and you know it's
it's the carelessness of the human
material you know that's the part to me
that's so galling and i
um you know as the war on terror you
know
kind of pushed forward i'd see it more
and more just
badly used people lives destroyed
unnecessarily i mean war is war
but
you know
there's a kind of carelessness that only
people who risk nothing who are never
going to be near it who have never felt
the hard hand of it or seen the
aftermath of it
that they can they can entertain these
fantasies and do it without remorse and
do it over and over again
um yeah i mean you found out
um through your interviews joseph
hargrove like i said was captured with a
leg wound and executed pretty quickly
yeah
but it was a week later yeah that they
captured gary hall and danny marshall so
those guys were on the island you got
massive american forces around there
that could have done any number of
things to try and get those guys out
and they just got yeah and they want and
so you had the marine officers
volunteered to go back the seals wanted
to go back
i think the pjs had gone back to
thailand but the wayne fisk of
unbelievable pj was on the sante raid
and you know the apollo missions i mean
he
um you know you had all the all the the
people ready to do the heavy lifting
without any qualms about doing it and uh
and they just steamed away and left them
you know left them behind gone and
you know and that's uh they were
stealing rice from the khmer rouge and
so basically they finally saw boot
prints going into their kitchen because
every day the khmer rouge guys hey
why'd you eat the leftover rice i didn't
eat the leftover rice no you did you
know so they're fighting about this and
then
they get they go to msum and they the
same accounts of the rice missing uh is
happening over and over so then they say
okay there's still two guys here so
let's set up an ambush they capture them
coming at night to get the rice
and they're at this point so physically
beaten down they don't even bother to
tie them up and in fact
according to khmer rouge they made them
rice and made them food and they just
waited for their orders and then they
sent them to the mainland
then they were put in a prison then they
were and probably interrogated and
executed
so where's what's the status of this
book
right now
um
uh you know probably ten years you know
no it's been more than ten years um
it's uh
it's a hard sell and it's funny that's
like oh you know we don't want another
book about the vietnam war that's what
my agent was saying and i said look this
isn't this is about
this is about
you know leave no man behind this is as
old as warfare this is a a much bigger
kind of theme so we'll see i'll peck
away at it and
um but yeah there's not much interest in
the vietnam war not that much interest
in this subject what's it what's causing
the lack of interest in the vietnam war
i think there were too many books uh
initially there was just a big spate of
books and
it's just publishing now you know
publishing isn't
doing that well and everybody's nervous
the economy is going funny it's just
like well that's one of the reasons for
that is because you can publish a book
with no yeah by yourself yeah you know
echo charles could publish a book in a
week yeah you could literally publish a
book in a week yeah and it could be
available on amazon and it could have
which is 85 of book sales or amazon sure
right now anyway so so echo charles
could write a book about
uh bicep curls yes sir and since that's
your area of expertise
and he could have it published
immediately yeah and he could have
access to 85 of the market yeah which is
a pretty unbelievable thing sure and so
yes the publishers are definitely scared
about that
but i need to go back i got to go back
to cambodia and do some more interviews
and
um
would you if you're going to make you've
made that much effort you've made this
much effort now you're going to make
some more effort
if no if your publisher doesn't want to
publish it what are you going to do
you're going to publish it yourself sure
eventually but you know i i have like
three jobs so
it's you know it's uh
i
have to write a lot of stuff to pay the
bills and then i uh what do you normally
write to pay the bills
a lot of ghost writing some
screenwriting
um yeah
have you written any screenplays that
we've seen
no not yet nothing you know it's
hollywood where everything almost always
happens
uh i wrote i co-wrote the screenplay for
the hixson movie
and uh is that coming
that's battling with netflix because now
netflix is all you know taking on water
and they're all panicking and um i wrote
a couple of pilots for the thai stick tv
series
i wrote kelly slater by the the rights
to tie stick he did but then he fumbled
him and uh yeah he had a deal with sony
and then
it's just hollywood and it's it's just
it makes the dod
seem positively efficient same thing is
going on though too with like hollywood
because if you want to you could make a
movie and you can post it on youtube and
see what happens well and the thing is
like the hixson movie is remarkable
because it starts with maida
so it starts in 1890
in japan and maida is an unbelievable
guy i mean he's prize fighting all over
europe he comes the united states like
in the 20s he's prize fighting in the
south he's he's going to west point
yeah and and then he fights
like one of the gangs in new york guys
in brooklyn
and and then he goes to cuba and then i
think we think he's the guy who invented
the mexican wrestling mask because no
one would fight him
and then he winds up in brazil with the
meets the gracies and then that's where
the second part of the story goes and
jose padilla who did narcos who's from
rio who grew up you know around hixon
and the gracies is the director so
it ain't rocket science yeah that's a
no-brainer yeah and you're kind of like
so
i would i think you're right i mean i
that's what i told jose padilla the
director i was like go get some private
equity people i mean this isn't that
tough a business case to make yeah come
on and that's not
not like a crazy special effects movie
or anything either like it's not going
to be a huge budget film it's big like
you know you got some great fights you
know you have like helio fighting um
camira uh no kimura but you also have uh
hit the the black panther his former
student oh okay and tara you know the
three-hour 48-minute fight and uh and
just classic stories that hixson talks
about like as his childhood
and um and so all that's in there and
it's just
you know you could see it rio in the 70s
and
you know surfing yeah drugs
street fights yeah yeah and so uh what's
not to like yeah so those i don't know i
just like when i write something for
hollywood i write it and i forget about
it about it and my mom luckily
i grew up around this and i you know i
grew up on the set of robert altman
movies and altman was all in altman was
putting his house on the line to pay for
that movie and there was none of this
committee decision like the greatest
oxymoron i've ever seen is what they
call in hollywood a creative executive
and
and so you go to these meetings about
meetings
and uh
and everybody has and then i get in
trouble because i'm not
nice enough or whatever and then i'm not
really allowed to go to meetings anymore
and um but the best meeting we had was
we went into ted sarandos owner of
netflix's office
and my co-author mike ritter glass like
a half a pound of weed in a 1970s single
fin pin tail and we had the tie stick
cover on top of it
and uh i pulled out a rubber mallet and
a chisel ripped the deck off of it and
put a half a pound of wheat in an
abalone shell and pushed it to tets
around us and there it is it's all yours
ted and he usually is like
and i was like nope i'm not taking it
back
leave it in your commissary whatever and
so i left a bunch of wheat at netflix
oh well hopefully some of those things
get eventually made man sounds like good
stuff yeah uh that kind of has us up to
date yeah we made it we made it through
your life to this point
um
what do we miss anything
no i don't i mean
yeah but no i think we got most of the
sailing points there the high points
yeah uh people can find you
at
faintingrobin.org if they want to
support that you've got your sub stack
which is petermaguire.substack.com
sour milk and it's peter mcguire's sour
milk
what's what's the title about why is it
called sour milk because i'm sour milk
i'm a 57 year old white guy
[Music]
uh you got your books law and order
i'm sorry law and war
facing death in cambodia tie stick and
then the book that i covered on podcast
293 i think with hicks and gracie the
book is called breathe i wrote the
forward and you did a great job and that
was the best interview anybody did on
that whole book tour oh well i
appreciate it it was absolutely
a absolute honor to be able to write
that forward um when you hit me up i was
like you know can you said can you write
a forward and i was like let me think
about that for yes i can well thank you
uh yeah that's just a great book and and
and now you're working on a follow-on
book with jackson yeah and what's the
premise of the follow-on book with
hixson uh it's called invisible
jiu-jitsu and it's visible
yeah and it's
there's a lot about jiu-jitsu in
fighting but there's also a lot about
life and a lot about
people dealing with problems and you
know similar to the things you talk
about and how the answer can't be found
in a pill
or a shrink and that you know you you
kind of have to
you you know there's sections on
strategy there's sections
on things hickson talks about generally
but then i make him you know delve into
in much greater detail and so i think
people will find it very useful for
their daily lives trying to get people
kind of back in their bodies and out of
their heads and i think there's really
something to that and we've been
teaching
a lot of really civilian unathletic
people really really basic jiu jitsu
and how someone's walking into you what
do you do you know do you let them close
the distance do you so kind of coming
back to the old self-defense jiu-jitsu
at a very fundamental level and uh and i
have all these kind of out-of-shape
civilian students i've been testing it
on and they come every week and they
love it even though they go drink 20
beers afterwards and get even more out
of shape but um but now they want to
roll and they're rolling and i got to be
careful that they don't get hurt because
they're not in the best shape but
you really see the change on them as
we've all seen with jiu jitsu it does
change people yeah i think
one thing with hixson is like
jiu-jitsu is so
much a part of him
that
there's you you kind of have to tease it
out of him it's like the water this is
the water that he lives in right and so
you ask him how the water tastes like
that fish story right how's the
how's the water they're like what what's
water yeah so you're you pulling out
because my
i
i connected so many things in my life
because of jiu jitsu it made all the
all the pictures start to become
assimilated into the same world
and that was huge absolutely huge for me
and so i think that you know if you pull
those strings on on hixson where he can
talk about
he makes a decision in life without
thinking about it because that's just
who he is but if you start saying hey
why'd you make that decision why would
you do it that way and then you can
he'll start to see and you'll start
seeing we'll all start to see that's the
jujitsu well like he talks about
acceptance you know and he he'll use
these words and you'll think it's kind
of a new age thing acceptance and then
forgiveness and i'll say what do you
mean acceptance he goes well
when fenaki broke my orbital bones in my
eye socket
i had to accept the fact that i couldn't
see and i was going to have to fight him
blind and i was figuring out how i was
going to fight him blind and i ca and i
had a plan
but then i got a little bit of vision
back and i took him down and you know
broke his knee and then choked him
unconscious and so
so it's funny because like you said to
to kind of force him to really elaborate
on some of this stuff
um the well is deep
no doubt awesome man uh echo any
questions oh so you have your black belt
yes when did that happen
uh
after 30 years i got it i don't know two
months ago or something oh you just got
your black belt yeah i have my black
belt in jeet kune do but yeah i was a
purple belt i think for like 17 years
well i only would take belts from hixson
so and i didn't i'm not out here all the
time so dude you're a black belt snob
listen to this guy he's like i'll only
take a black belt from him crazy that's
it yeah
yeah it does make sense though because
you started with hixson and then you
know like all your knowledge and stuff
like that is like from hixon and then
what some other guy kind of slides in
yeah he's like you know i trained with
hanzo too but you know it just
was different you know hicks and six and
i donna her i trained with a lot how
much did you train with enzo
not much because i was a daytime guy so
i trained with donahue and john was a
white belt i met him when he was a white
belt i was a professor at columbia when
he was a graduate student
and so you guys knew each other oh yeah
guys were bros yeah oh yeah and he
would kind of ramp me up for cambodia
you know so i just like take these
horrible donner beatings for a month so
that nothing was really that bad and
cambodia the legionnaires and stuff that
didn't know jiu-jitsu so coming out so
were you there when he quit being
whatever he was being at columbia and he
just yeah
yeah yeah and um
yeah and he i i was getting threatened
by the serbs and i was putting on this
conference and i had all these big
richard goldstone the chief prosecutor
and the hague and this and that and so
john donner and peretti my old
kickboxing coach came as the undercover
security and just shattered these two
serbs the whole time was it was pretty
funny but um yeah john downer actually
came to my wedding and wore a
three-piece suit he did not wear lycra
did he have a butt pack on
no donner was uh he was he's a classic
guy and we had a lot of fun and uh yeah
he was i could i could really
plumb the depths of my cynicism with
donner
well he's been awesome to watch him and
his team um
man they're just dominating jiu jitsu
it's freaking awesome well he's i mean
he's a
really sharp guy and um
and you know on some level i think they
saw my academy he saw my academic career
and was like no way man
i'm just going to teach you jitsu oh i
remember henzo and henzo and donner came
to one of my classes at columbia and i
was teaching about japan and the samurai
and this and that i had a student go um
i don't think it's appropriate for you
to to get into these co these cultural
stereotypes about the japanese warrior
culture they had almost 20 years of
weimar like democracy
just burying my head in my hands
and uh i think that was probably the day
decided he wasn't gonna become a
professor yeah well he's a professor of
jiu-jitsu oh yeah i'm sure he is it's
kind of wild you know
you've heard the story that like you
know dean lister is on seriously and he
he had that conversation with dean it's
kind of like this mythical thing now
right it's a little bit of a mythical
thing that dean said
you know dean was get catching guys and
dean tells it super humble you you know
i was doing okay with my leg locks
training with some of the students which
means people were he was good tapping
people out yeah i can tell you that
right now because he's tapped me out one
million times
and i've seen him we used to do you know
dojo storms and all that stuff and even
just tournaments he would just flock
leglock everybody um and win by other
methods because his whole game of
jiu-jitsu but it's kind of wild
you know like donahue
was asking him like you know or said
something like you know you spend a lot
of time on the you know going for
people's legs and and dean lister said
why would you ignore fifty percent of
the human body and that's become this
yeah yeah but it's
if you think about
the
the the sharpness of
of donohue to hear that and go hmm
that's a really good point oh yeah
that's a really good point and dean was
d d you know d it wasn't like
if you have the idea that dean was
had a couple foot locks in his game and
that's what no dean was way deep into
heal hooks foot locks he was way deeper
that stuff i mean
so far deep into it that people have
only caught up i think it's been now
it's about a year and a half when dean i
was i can't ask dean like hey have you
seen anything you didn't know yet it was
like a year and a half ago yeah now
they're starting to do things that i
don't know
but that was a long time where dean was
just way above everybody else but it is
amazing that donahue heard that saw what
he did and said oh yeah
there's something going on here and of
course now we have pete the greek
all right
yeah he's a wrist locker and he says why
would you ignore five percent of the
human yeah yeah
i trained with labelle also oh hell yeah
and so i tried i met him a few times and
he's scary and uh and so i have his book
you know he's got a big book about pro
wrestling finishing holds that one yeah
yeah i guess
he has more than one i got a big giant
book by judo jean labelle and it's all
these crazy finishing goals it also got
like weird like you have a cane and how
you can choke some with a cane and all
this other stuff well i grew up watching
him
uh
and uh you know that was wrestling at
the olympic and jean's brother was the
announcer and then jean was the hangman
jean was like three different mask guys
and uh and then you know when you train
with him he goes into character and
he'll get you in some horrible weird
neck twist me like who's the most
beautiful man in the world and um yeah
he's a scary guy
he i mean judo jean labelle he has to be
one of the premier guys and and for
whatever reason it like didn't make it
out
you know like the gracies
did the most incredible job of marketing
jiu jitsu by creating the ufc yeah and
jean labelle had some
some mma fights oh yeah and he left what
was the big fight he referenced
yes right and okinawa he refereed that
fight yeah but again it wasn't quite
it didn't quite get over the hump and
maybe ufc wouldn't have made it over the
hump because you know the fertitta
brothers it was banned everywhere and it
got eventually got picked up but man
judo gene lebel
he he was a legit submission grappler
before that was even a thing well he was
aau wrestling champ god what a beast he
was all japan judo champ at some point
first american yeah and his mom
i think
owned the olympic auditorium or ran it
something like that so he grew up
training with like ed strangler lewis
the legit catch wrestlers yeah yeah the
catches catch can guys so
he didn't know anything but like you
know real nasty old-fashioned submission
grappling and um and yeah and then you
i got to go to his cabin at high
elevation and you show up there at like
10 at night and uh where was it a big
bear or something yeah and you trained
till like three in the morning and it
was me peretti and john lewis and uh
and
and we walk in and his wife says oh hi
boys
and john lewis is so nervous he goes uh
uh it's nice to know you and then and
there's a loft and we hear this booming
voice from the loft
you know it's nice to know her you just
met her
and so
but he actually surfed uh
with lord taliho blears who was the old
announcer for pro surfing who was a a
wrestler in hawaii so and taliho blears
took him to makaha like on a big day and
like lobel got his front teeth knocked
out and gene was terrified of surfing
and so like and i was surfing a lot of
big waves then and i must had a picture
or something so i wound up at his
kitchen table like talking to him it's
about surfing for hours and uh and he
was very close to the machados and i
think
you know jean-jacques machado is one of
the guys who's impressed me
as much as anyone other than hixson yeah
and i've been able to train with him in
the last few years um and that's been
great and he's he's a really nice guy
and
that's a book i'd like to write
what about jean-jacques yeah because
being born or judo jean labelle uh both
but but i think jean's a little more
plays it close to the vest
but john jacques born with one hand and
becoming you know one of the best of all
time and turning a handicap into an
advantage is uh it's a remarkable story
and he and again he's uh a great teacher
did you run into the armenian crew oh
yeah go-kart yeah yeah yeah yeah this
was like a whole timeline oh yeah and
dean and we were going up there and like
those guys were we we did matches in
these underground places there was one
place called neutral grounds it was in
some terrible part of
uh
uh l.a and like there was pit bulls
everywhere and there was no like
it's just just mayhem but it's hard to
explain that to people that
didn't live through that the precambian
times i thought dean killed an armenian
one time like this guy
these guys would not tap no i mean they
were it was a life-or-death scenario for
them oh yeah and
and they were i mean obviously tough as
hell
and and they you know they they also
knew they were also foot locking and
kneeling oh yeah they had they were all
linked in with judo jean labelle so
there's a mayhem going up there so
awesome times yeah there were some
there were some uh definite chaos
between jiu jitsu
and
i guess
[__] maybe yeah at jiu jitsu
tournaments yeah and it would be mayhem
but it was fun it was a good way to
start to learn things everybody got a
lot better fast yeah no doubt about it
and now it's like you you got to just
have an open mind with everything yeah
you know you got to keep that mind open
um
anyways man yeah a few more things oh
we've got more questions yeah from echo
charts rewind back to tahiti right you
were talking about the guy
who who is who's that guy her husband
the sugar daddy oh the sugar dude from
paris
landed from paris brutal showed up
unannounced and start smelling the
sheets
so you were just out
passport where is it yeah where is it
that's probably the most everything
you've done that might have been the
closest to death you've been yeah
and then back to your weed uh selling
days you said you didn't like to do the
small stuff no only do like bigger like
how does that work where would you get
it from or whatever from the older guys
who were smuggling it okay so you had to
deal with like
the older guys yeah but they were guys i
knew from surfing it was very small
closed loop it wasn't and they would
what sell it to you yeah you'd sell it
yeah yeah basically and it didn't want
exposure didn't want you know people
coming to my house or whatever it was
just
go to mcdonald's and
bring in the duffel bag and they leave
with the duffel bag or you know
usually but the crenshaw stuff was you'd
sit on the front porch and you know that
was a trip like that was a whole nother
world
what was going on there well that was um
it was
just out in the open you know and and i
had a i had a white mustang gt and when
that white mustang gt pulled up like
line would form and people coming from
all walks of life all ages everything
and uh
and i remember once
these cars came screeching up and i was
like oh man it's a drive-by and uh and
they get out and they just robbed the
crenshaw high school
marching band
and so they have sounds like a great
taste so they haven't got a trombone and
so they're trying to run up on on the
porch of the house where i am to stash
the stuff and my buddy's mom comes out
no no no they're not putting that here
so i was like get that [__] out of here
then there's like 10 guys walking down
the street with like crenshaw cougars
big drums
tubes and stuff
like oh man yeah so i i
li uh the truth is always stranger than
fiction
you know it really is and it's just you
know yeah how much money you think when
you went on your eight or nine month
trip to australia and and southeast asia
and whatnot
how much money do you think you had in
your how much money did you have in your
bank account when you rolled out uh
probably like 20 grand or something
that's like more than enough yeah live
forever yeah and my rent in australia
was
it was like 300 australian a month right
across the street from a little grass
trail to broken head point
and uh you know go to the pub
and uh you know play pool in the
afternoons and yeah it was great and uh
yeah and then the
the banquet for the surf contest i was
in a few surf contests always had to
culminate with a giant wild wild west
fight and uh and
the bondi guys were real bad asses so
ant and the bondi guys would come up and
it was the big one was the sky easter
classic and so
we were all in that and then then some
guys from malibu came and they started
slam dancing
at the
at the awards banquet and the aussies
thought they were fighting and it turns
into the gnarliest wild wild west brawl
you've ever seen
and um
yeah and and uh one of the americans got
his lips split a little bit and you know
it just comes with the turf
and uh
yeah no i love the aussies uh yeah i
still talk i'm still friends with all
those guys yeah i was lucky enough to go
down there for a bit and um
it was one of the places where i was
like man i went to
damn noosa oh yeah
what the that place is ridiculous oh
yeah no no but see then i started going
to west australia and that's gnarly and
so by then i was pretty good in jiu
jitsu and they called me the human knot
and um and my
friends
it's like four brothers and they're the
best guys at margaret river so i would
stay with them but i would first have to
line them all up on the lawn and beat
all of them just to get it over with and
i would also have a mouthpiece with me
anytime i went out
and so and they worked these are hard
guys they worked all day on the blacktop
shoveling blacktop and uh and the father
was a treasure hunter deep sea diver
and they were also commercial fishermen
and they come home and their little
council worker outfits with his short
shorts and the one brother
who was the wimpiest one but he was the
natural in jiu jitsu so suddenly he's
whipping the brothers who've been
kicking his ass his whole life and he's
like
and he's really looks scared i go
what's wrong jay he goes well cousin
dave's a bit crook with you and i'm like
[__] cousin dave i don't know your
cousin dave i go what are you talking
about he goes well i've gone and showed
him that choke and he said no seppo
choke's gonna work on me so i've gone
and shouted but but i forgot to tell him
to tap my leg and he's gone unconscious
on the job site and so then
i'd go to these parties and like cousin
dave want to give me the king hit which
is a sucker punch so you're having to
like always keep your back to the wall
and watch out for cousin dave
so and then there was gentlemen's night
at the margaret reverse board riders
club which was
um
you know an endless glass of beer for
three hours
then the fully naked strippers and then
the motorcycle club
crashed that party to fight with the
surfers
then
then i and this was like a normal
wednesday night no this is a big event
you know yeah and so no so we're there
and you know stumble drunk in true
australian fashion and the whole front
window shatters and the bikies are here
the barkies are here so they spill out
and there's some fighting with the
motorcycle guys and then
i'm thinking like i can't really stay
vertical but if i jog slow it's a lot
better so i'm kind of jogging slow
and uh
and and then and then i see a cop and
i'm like oh man i gotta that cop's gonna
get me for public drunkenness or
something and then i kind of get lost
and now i'm in west australia it's like
two in the morning and then i sort of
get my bearings again i'm like okay and
i can see where i'm staying
and i'm going down the main dragon
margaret river
and uh there was like a crazy australian
vietnam vet who lived in the park and
all he did was march with this big staff
on his head and do push-ups and
bodyweight exercises and he was a
monster and and i'm lurking in the
shadows and i hear this i see you
oh see you scaredy cat come on scaredy
cat come out and fly
and uh and i go down one block and
there's like three blocks to my place
where i'm staying i put my mouthpiece in
and i just start running and i'm like
okay it's football time and he didn't do
anything but then i wake up the next day
i'm so hungover
and my my wife says oh let's go out
breakfast i say okay yeah i
you're married at this point yeah
so
my wife's gnarly and uh and so i take
like two steps and run back throw up and
i said i just got to go to the beach and
get in the water and i'll be better like
just let me get in the water so you go
to margaret river you got to go down
this long staircase and then there's a
big beach with some rocks and i'm with
walking with my wife and i get halfway
down the beach i'm like
and my wife just peels off like she's
never seen me in my life there's like
one twig i'm trying to hide under and
puke and all the aussies are up on the
thing watching the whole thing and
that's when they're like ah that plate's
a top bloke and that's like australia
you have to do that you know what what
year did you get married
uh 2 000.
wait a second so this was
oh
yeah that was her that was that was the
final she's according to she's like yeah
that was your courting process yeah and
a little time an up wedge island at the
lobster camp she liked that a
lot where's she from originally south uh
she's from
virginia and florida
but a real southerner where when did you
meet her uh blind ate new york city
in 95 i think something so again how was
she was she doing down now this [__] was
happening in australia like
i took her down 95. no no this would
this would have been about
probably
97 or 8 or somewhere around then oh so
you were actually a grown man doing this
yeah
i still i thought this was when you were
18. no no but but in australia you say
oh well that was back then everybody's
old now and these guys all have kids and
all that and then they're still down the
pub oh no and then the two brothers that
night went home and got in a fist fight
with each other
on the way home and then they had to
drive like four hours to perth in the
car one with a black eye them not
talking and the kids in the back
and yeah it's the aussie way
that's how we roll i guess
um
awesome man
thank you uh appreciate you coming on uh
thanks for thanks for joining us thanks
for sharing your experiences
um i'd say thanks for reminding us that
life's a story and and in order to write
it you've got to go live it yep so good
lesson for all of us go out there and
live thanks for joining us man thank
you and with that peter mcguire has left
the building
echo charles surfing jiu jitsu
academia uh genocide a lot going on in
there yeah
definitely
an interesting path
and and it's a good thing to remember
that when you're on a path you can step
off that path and go in a different
direction yeah you know this isn't i'm
not talking about the
i'm not talking about the path right
capital t capital p yeah yeah we don't
want to say you could be going down one
lane
of the road
and you could get off and go down a
different lane
and it was kind of hard to convey this
but a lot of this stuff was happening in
in peter's life was happening at the
same time he's doing jiu jitsu he's
going to cambodia he's writing about
this he's still a profes like he did a
lot a lot of stuff was he was living it
was happening parallel in his life
so that is definitely something to
remember
sometimes i think people feel stuck in a
rut
and the reason they feel stuck in a rut
is because they're staying in the rut
that they're in and you don't have to
sacrifice everything to go and you know
put another toe in the water over here
or test the waters over there you know
you can you can go and try jiu-jitsu
class you can go and take a guitar class
you can go and
do some research about something that
you don't know much about you can go and
interview people that's what does it
cost to interview somebody doesn't cost
anything go learn yeah a lot of
opportunity out there
man i was
so surfing is one of those things you
just like this too but surfing is a big
one and you see you know you see movies
about this or whatever right the even
idea of the endless summer right where
you're chasing like essentially you're
chasing waves right you can go ahead and
say it what point break point break okay
so
that's what i that's what i uh
[Music]
so i don't have to work right right
even though he was working other jobs
but still the idea is there where
they'll rob all the banks and do all
this and then just surf and skydive and
stuff the rest of time and that's kind
of the dream right or you could just
join the teams
yeah but here's the here's the point
with that and actually you're right
though you're right where
if you go around the world chasing waves
where you you'll just by incident
find yourself in different interesting
situations where you'll learn new things
meet new people
have all these like varying levels of
craziness experiences
and then that builds on itself right you
know you know how you like one
experience with this experience put
together it's like oh that's also and
jiu-jitsu is like that as well where but
most people don't travel around just
doing jiu-jitsu sometimes you do
sometimes they do and actually i had
that experience on a small degree when i
was traveling around
filming jiu-jitsu yeah but i was i would
train too so that's how i met at that
time all the main guys and they'd be
like yeah come train because i'd be
purple belt in brown belt so it's like
the perfect guy for them to train with
because
i'm usually their size or whatever
not good enough you know so it's easy to
it kind of they can beat me up at the
same time and then give me the
experience of their gym and all this
stuff it's like hospitality thing it was
perfect yeah and so i got that trans
freaking everybody
that is a good thing and then you get
all these experiences and now you know
them
oh you know how he knew all these people
you're like eric balzing you know like
all these people and he knew them all
but it's because of that same concept
where he's like he's going around
chasing waves you know oh uh
hixon's here okay i'll take a jiu-jitsu
class or whatever and i'm gonna meet
this guy now i know this guy you know
it's kind of crazy how many like that
from one level of connection to john
donna her and then john donna heard of
dean lister and we got judo g lebel you
got eric paul like all these are
these guys are the premier people that
brought the sport to what it is you know
i mean i i mean obviously you've got
hixson and horian and alia like for sure
but then you have all like the second
gen people
that were coming up and it's just
it's just interesting how it's all
connected
and it seems
i guess it seems more interesting to me
because jiu jitsu is such a big part of
my world you know takes up a big part of
my world takes a big part of your world
and
i but still like the connection between
like john donahue
henzo gracie
hicks and gracie
peter maguire
gene labelle like it's just wildness
it's wildness so
uh i say
you know i i heard this some expression
about like if you want to be a writer
well what's the best thing you do if you
want to be a writer go live oh yeah
that's a great advice you want to be a
writer go live
somebody asked me yesterday
where was i
oh yeah when we were up yesterday i got
asked um
you know oh did you always want to be a
writer i'm like nope
now i've written i think 11 books but i
didn't quote like i was like oh i'm
going to be a writer yeah
i just was going to be a commando and
then
happen to start writing but that's a
good it's not a bad and i'm not saying
you have to be a commando but maybe
you're going to be of a a damn jiu jitsu
player or maybe you're going to be a
surfer or maybe you're going to be
anything
go out and be something you'll have
something to write about at least yeah
take a little bit of risk too what was
the quote he said about being careful
careful gets you killed careful gets you
killed yeah yeah careful kills yeah
careful kills but also careful prevents
life prevents living and look i'm not
saying obviously go on do dumb [__]
but yeah don't
but don't let caution
guide your every move where you don't
take you've got to take risks you're
going to be out there get getting after
it no look does it is it smart to
smuggle pot no it's not
but
is it smart to hey i don't have too much
money but i got enough money to get down
the you know down to indonesia i'm gonna
go surfing oh cool yeah you know don't
do dummy legal [__]
but man roll the dice a little bit go
get after it a little bit yeah it's
gonna be good for you yeah it's almost
like within a certain certain threshold
it's like you
that's the best thing you can actually
do for yourself within reasons for sure
if you would look at it and be like hey
this is dumb this is a dumb move you
know illegal stuff mainly like falls
within that category or whatever um
then okay that's exclude that everything
else should kind of be in play in a way
when you think about it
seriously yeah just and between the and
of course on on one superficial end
you've got a cool story that's
unsupervised but like all the stuff you
learn whether you're successful or not
it's like by the stuff you learn you'd
be surprised how valuable that ends up
becoming yup go get some experience go
live a little bit
that's the recommendation but the other
thing is to remember is it's not too you
know you can be i'm 50.
i still need to go out there and get
after a little bit more i need to take a
little bit more chances in the world i
will say and maybe maybe you disagree
but
i would say it gets harder and harder
though as well you know take on more uh
fixed responsibility that is true that's
100 true from a financial thing but i'm
not even and also in other ways it comes
easier
because now you got money like remember
when you had no money yeah yeah and you
you know you were working as a
whatever i almost feel like and maybe i
guess it depends on the circumstance but
i almost feel like when you have no
money it kind of pushes you to have to
do more stuff you know so if you have
money i'll just pay for it oh just
whatever whatever whatever kind of a
thing where it's like things will come a
lot easier
and i thought about this too where
you know how like when you think back to
the times when you don't make any money
it's like wha what was the difference
because 20 years i was in the navy
but think about it that there are
certain parts it's funny i say that but
you know what i at the time and you've
heard me say this like i was the richest
guy in the world me and my friends
we thought we were the richest guys in
the world we had so much money young
single team guy an e5 frogman get some
in your position too you get a lot of
stuff
paid for right by the name you know like
well wet suits right yeah guns a lot of
the fresh events
yeah and that's a huge deal yeah ammo
yeah what people would want to spend
money on yeah you could have batteries
toilet paper oh yeah
right so that's
a little bit different my buddy had
freaking went to his house you know like
the big industrial toilet paper rolls
that are like a foot across
that's what they had in the seal teams
and this dude had it at his house i was
like bro
you're a savage wasn't even gonna pay
for his own toilet paper taking a
freaking roll of
that role probably last like six months
here's the thing a year here's the the
thing and actually which is part of the
fraud waste and abuse by the way
fraud wasted abuse
is though those things in life cost
money and if you don't have a lot of
money like certain parts little little
tiny parts of life that all are then
there's a lot of them too a lot of them
every day all day those little parts of
life are hard yeah it's like
they're so hard that you're taking
toilet paper from this yeah you know
guys batteries
there's kind of an unlimited supply of
batteries in the seal teams oh yeah uh
oh yeah any kind of riggers tape like
what do you call it gaff tape sure
yeah that stuff you go to guys you go to
a team guy's house there's a freaking
pretty good there's a box of riggers
tape just in case some 550 cord some one
inch tubular nylon yep
so think about this
let's say let's say you don't get free
riggers tape and toilet paper and yeah
hotels places to stay like these are
if you have if you have money orgy you
get that stuff free it's kind of like it
makes it things so much easier but it
keeps you in a little bit more of a box
than if you didn't so let's say this i'm
a jujitsu bomb surfbomb whatever i don't
have like i don't sell weed i don't rob
banks i have normal uh i have to get a
normal job i don't have that much money
but i want to go to australia
first off i'm not flying first class in
this cozy thing and no one bothering me
i'm
i might even write in the cargo part and
then have a good story or whatever but
in you being coach or whatever you're
going to meet some weird dude or maybe
you know or maybe some weird girl or
something like this right
then you go to australia now you got to
search for a place to stay
it's not taking care of any adventures
you know exactly right many adventures
because you gotta you gotta like make do
you gotta struggle for everything and
and it becomes more of a thing if you
have money you're just like yeah you
probably don't even book it you're like
hey can you just book me in that hotel
just choose the nicest one or kind of a
thing so you don't have a story behind
that you're safe in the hotel you're
safe in your box you see what i'm saying
if you'd have money you're out there
earning every little teeny tiny thing so
you have way more of a
um experience it's insane
embrace it risky too yeah
all right well hey take some chances go
out there um if you want to support the
podcasts you want to support yourself
you want to get stronger faster better
smarter
get yourself some jackal fuel new
flavors in discipline go
new flavors get yourself some milk i
need some milk right now bro here and
here bro how's this and i i'm with you
right you know how like you know kind of
when you get you know when you get
hungry and then like even like a normal
chocolate bar or something seems like oh
like wait you know just when you get
real hungry bro
i i mixed banana milk and chocolate milk
and i put some chocolate milk in it yeah
just cause you know how everything
sounds good to you is what i'm saying so
i was like oh yeah put some banana in
there whatever and probably it was
really really good i don't know if it's
because i was so hungry or because that
could be a banana chocolate is good
wait it was a chocolate peanut butter so
that made sense think about it you you
chop up a banana put some peanut butter
on it i mean in real life not milk
and then put a little bit of chocolate
on there come on bro that's good
it's the same flavor as what i'm saying
yeah so yeah well get yourself some milk
that way you it's just so good
especially like like i'm saying right
now so it's pretty standard that when
that
we are here
when we're recording i haven't eaten
yeah so have you eaten today no so we're
both on a fast right now yeah it all
sounds good i'm gonna break the fast
with like some mixed nuts and some milk
when i get done with this little
scenario so
i recommend you do the same thing get
yourself some more get yourself some
discipline go
and uh you can get all that at
jackalfield.com you can also get it at
we get the drinks at wawa we got the
ready to drink coming
ready to drink protein all the way like
a date or anything on that august
by the end of august it'll be in wawa
it'll be
we're not able to make enough of it yet
to get it everywhere
but we'll get it out there i'll let you
know where it's at um you'll be able to
order it i can tell you that yeah from
jockofield.com
you can get stuff at vitamin shop as
well we get a heb down in texas we're
going into some other
they're putting a list together because
there's a huge we're in a
bunch of different stores now thousands
and thousands of stores so i'll
get a list together so i can tell
everyone where to go and hit it yeah so
there you go uh originusa.com
if you need jiu jitsu gear you've gone
look if you're not doing jiu jitsu right
now come on
let's go let's just get in the game get
yourself a ghee go to originusa.com get
american made gee don't get someone
don't get a ghee that's made by someone
that's basically in a prison camp bro
have you ever called
have you ever been at home or wherever
wherever you go
and just thought to yourself i wish i
was like doing jiu jitsu right now yes
and not the kind where it's like oh i
wish i was doing something else jujitsu
sounds fun so that i'm you like the
feeling of man i wish i was actually
like
doing jiu-jitsu with someone right now
you know what i had the feeling similar
feeling but like so dean's had an
injured hand because he broke his hand
for like a couple months right and you
know so when whenever we're training
there's a little bit of a little bit of
hold back right a little bit of oh hey
you know hey switch arms hey switch
positions hey
oh hold on
you know that kind of hurt that kind of
thing and like the other day we actually
like he i had forgotten he'd hurt in his
hand because he's been hit all taped up
you know so when you're rolling you just
see this taped up thing and then i was
gone for a little few days i come back
he didn't put the tape on because it's
healing and we're just rolling
and when we got done
he said something like you know my hand
felt pretty good today i was like oh i
didn't even remember it but the roll was
so fun because it was like the limits
were off yeah yeah and it was just like
felt so good yeah so yes sometimes you
got to train that jiu jitsu yes
yeah fully you ever and this is not a
judgmental thing by any means
but you ever um you ever think about
yourself before you knew jiu jitsu and
be like man i felt like that was almost
like an empty shell version of myself
you ever think that
you feel like you were not enlightened
yes you feel like there was just a whole
thing it was all a lot a lot of it too
is like a lie what's there's another
word what is the word like the buddhist
use
to say is an illusion
you were i was a little bit of an
illusion because there's a lot of things
that you think that are wrong yeah just
just to straight up even
even just the pragmatic things like i
think i can beat this person up
and you don't know jujitsu you think
that but it's an illusion yeah because
you may or may not sure you might be
able to but you also might not be able
to yeah so there's a whole illusion to
your life when you're not doing jiu
jitsu that's a problem
yes and this is
you're actually su her absolutely
correct and you're you know more about
what i was just said than i do actually
because now that you say that i'm
remembering yes that's correct because i
was a bouncer in hawaii before i started
jiu-jitsu oh yeah you thought you were
the best and i i didn't ever really
thought i was back because i worked with
a bunch of big someone guys so i did not
think i was fat ass but yeah yeah
probably yeah probably related to him
but i didn't think i was a badass in
that group but compared to the patrons
that would act up and stuff i did
but i think of myself back then i was
like almost like there was this big part
of my brain that was just empty not
knowing unknowing you know so yes not
enlightened exactly right did you see
they're making apparently they're making
a remake of roadhouse yes yes you're
fired up for that that pisses me off
it doesn't piss me off but i just i know
it's going to be lame well it's conor
mcgregor so what what what who's conor
mcgregor conor mcgregor he's he's in it
he's slated given what i've been sent
you know what's funny you're the third
person now to to bring actually cause
everybody knows you're interested
they've been sending me this stuff yeah
and so conor mcgregor is going to be in
it playing what role well the online
stuff that people sent me um
had a picture of conor mcgregor to be in
roadhouse
that's different he's gonna be in it
he's gonna have a bit rolled that's cool
no i think he's the guy but i don't know
i didn't i didn't he's dalton
that's what i think no i
a bunch of people just been sending it
to me and then people have been bringing
it up too there's a lot of roles that
conor mcgregor would be awesome at
dalton's not one of them in my opinion i
don't know you think so i don't i have
no idea i think he'd be better as the as
the protagonist in that the person the
antagonist yeah
yeah
the dude that gets his throat ripped out
yeah remember that oh do you want
something like that well well here's the
thing so
my
fantasy of a roadhouse remake would be a
super dark and gritty one not like kind
of cheesy like real dark with drugs and
like a real um explicit that was my og
fantasy then i found out later that
ronda rousey in her heyday was slated as
dalton as a remake of roadhouse where
you know it's a woman protagonist that's
what i
that's the intel i got this was back in
the day a long time ago
and then yes recently maybe that's why
because my vision of roadhouse was more
like an actual fighter guy yeah and
maybe it was just embedded my brain and
you don't see women bouncers so it's
like
that's i think a big time of mistake
when you're trying to sell a certain
story and it's like okay let's put like
a different
person in that role that's like bro
that's not that realistic as a woman
bouncer they're so rare so unless it's
about the rarity of women bouncers cool
but it's like it's not as believable you
know you know how like you get like a um
like a
like if you've got a ninja we'll say but
the ninja is a 10 year old boy
it's like
i see what you're doing but it's like
brad ninjas aren't 10 year old boys
typically ninjas is like a trained
decades of training guy that's who we're
going to believe you see what i'm saying
anyway so when i saw conor mcgregor i
was like hey i feel like that's viable
this is what i thought i think character
wise i think he would have more fun
playing like a bad guy i think you're
right right i think you're a great
antagonist because even though he's good
he's not good at talking smack he's kind
of good
he's kind of good at being a bad guy in
mma
but also has like the good side right
they love him he's not just a pure heel
you know what they term heel is right
from wrestling like like chael sonnen
was dude he was you know bad guy inc bro
yeah and he was so good at it
and and conor
plays that role a little bit
but he's not but he still does it with
like a nice side and he has a lot of you
know a lot of positivity to him
and so if he was allowed to just go off
and just be bad he'd have a good time
with it well here's the thing and and i
didn't realize this until it was
actually like told to me where the i
felt it but i never knew this as a
specific thing so the best bad guys in
history are guys that we like
like guys who were like hey sure he's a
bad guy but oh i kind of want to be like
him and that always has to have a
positive element to it like darth vader
um
like they're they're usually like guys
who are like sure they're all you know
you just
you just gave me a list of one
yeah you started counting your fingers
too like you're gonna have at least five
give me a list of one and it's freaking
darth vader good job
he was the first guy that came there all
right uh well you tell me who who is
who's like an iconic bad guy
anton sugar okay oh yeah okay so
stoicism is stoic dude right in touch
with or able to control his emotions
super successful
like there's all these elements of him
that are like and then there's one or
two really i mean they're significant
but this is usually just one or two bad
elements of them and in fact you get bad
guys who sometimes some movies they do
it on purpose and they do it well where
if they want you to really not like a
bad guy like they'll make him like kind
of weasley or someone who like you
wouldn't want to like listen to or hang
out with in fact you'd really rather be
quiet and not show up to the party kind
of a thing
but usually the good bad guys you're
like
as long as he liked me i would like to
hang out with that guy or be like that
guy when you think about it so you get a
conor mcgregor as the bad guy yeah
perfect and you said cheryl sonnen
chelsea and yeah he is a little bit more
on the like antagonistic side for sure
but he has a lot of those elements he's
smart he's funny yeah like right you
kind of like him dude some of the chael
sonnen uh like smack talking
i don't know it entered the algorithm it
entered my algorithm
and dude he was freaking epic man he was
he was just epic as smack talker and
just
i think he might be the king yeah i
think he might actually be the the best
smack talker of all time
anything
fourth round fifth round fifth round
he talked the biggest smack to anderson
silva oh yeah and he was in the fifth
round and there was a minute left man
and he got caught
brutal that was savage that was savage
that was a that was hard well
for i was rooting you know for him
what was his nickname
the
american bad guy inc or something well
bad guy inc is like his uh
video channel he's got a youtube channel
and he talks you know about mma and
stuff like that yeah
but uh he would say he's a gangster from
westland oregon yeah
he's like i'm an american i'm a gangster
he's freaking legit it's so funny i've
been to his house before
for for interview stuff okay so um and
this was back so you know
yeah a little bit you guys go way back
yeah like when i last saw like for
example last time i saw him a different
thing
we remembered each other for sure but i
don't you know i don't have one speed
dial nothing like this but yes i've been
to his house when i went to it's just me
and
yeah that's a real nice place he lives
in that whole neighborhood's super nice
what westland oregon wesleyan oregon
he's a gangster from west london
oregon yeah
i salute that
so there you go hey if you want to get
into jiu-jitsu go to origin usa.com go
to jacquardstore.com get yourself some
cool t-shirts to wear yeah represent
represent standard issue is that is out
oh the standard issue discipline
disciplines freedom
people asked
what's the layer
see if you can figure out what the
layers are you got to look at them kind
of comprehensively there's four of them
four versions
each one is a little bit different yeah
they're
yeah see if you can figure out those
layers it's good yeah a lot of cool
other stuff on there too yeah uh jocko
underground.com
youtube we got a youtube channel
we got psychological warfare we got
flipside canvas dakota meyer making cool
stuff to hang on your wall bunch of
books hey here's the books from peter
mcguire breath
which is or sorry breathe
with with hicks and gracie
uh thai stick law and war
facing death in cambodia so check those
out check out only cry for the living by
holly mckay
i was telling peter about her i'm like
dude this girl risked this woman is girl
insulting
i don't think so just like is boy
insulting okay this woman
risked her life to write the book only
cry for the living so check out that
book if you want to know what
what war is like from both sides while
it's happening
get yourself that book i i mentioned my
book final spin publishers weekly
gave me a good review thank you
publishers weekly hey publishers weekly
you didn't like breathe
that's a bummer it's a good book check
it out
i've written a bunch of other books
about leadership i've written a bunch of
kids books get the kids books for the
kids you know it's going to help them
it's going to make the world a better
place echelon front we solve problems
through leadership if you want to check
out or if you need help with leadership
at your organization go to
ashlandfront.com
come to one of our events next one is
atlanta we have the muster
everything we do sells out that's going
to sell out too so if you want to come
go to echelonfront.com get the details
there extremeownership.com we have an
online training academy
where you can be a part of
what we teach you can learn it you can
train it all the time we have live
interaction we have
courses that are set up
extremeownership.com
also if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help out
their families gold star families
mark lee
mark lee's mom
she's got a charity organization if you
want to donate or you want to get
involved you want to help out our
veterans and their families go to
americasmightywarriors.org
also
heroes and horses.org
we got micah fink up there taking guys
and recreating their brains and bodies
and spirits in the woods
on horses and ice baths
so there you go and if you want to check
us out on social media
on twitter on the gram
on the face bookie
echo's out of control i'm at jocko
willing
of course beware of the algorithm
because it's looking to suck you in it's
looking to grab a hold of your brain
that's what they did to me they got me
watching these chael sewn and smack talk
videos and now i'm now they're just
loading them up for me and i'm like what
he says on this one click
watch out watch out for the algorithm
it'll grab you uh thanks for listening
thanks for supporting the cause we
we would not be here without you
listening and supporting so thank you we
would also not be here
if it wasn't for
the military doing what the military
does so thanks to all military members
past present and future thank you for
protecting our freedom and our way of
life and also thank you to our police
and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all the first responders thank you for
doing what you do to keep us safe here
on the home front
and everyone else out there
listen to someone like peter maguire is
a great reminder
for all of us that there is so much
going on in the world
so much to do
so much to experience
and for peter that meant surfing and jiu
jitsu and reading and writing and
traveling and maybe some smuggling and
some studying and some teaching and so
much more there's so much going on in
the world there's experiences waiting to
be experienced there's sites waiting to
be seen
and there's life
waiting to be lived
so go live it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out